Monal S: Hey, everyone. Good morning, guys. Good morning.
Monal S: Morning, good morning, everyone.
Monal S: Hello, guys, hello, hello.
Monal S: Anthony, you were waiting for that big message, right?
Monal S: Tantun, have you checked the ZIP assignment? I've also added that.
Monal S: Have you checked out assignment folder?
Monal S: Good morning, guys, good morning. How many of you… Com- came revised here?
Monal S: Revised with the concepts.
Monal S: Guys, if you have not revised, then I will suggest to not move forward, at least in this class, because if you don't know the basics of cells, class, methods, and everything, it is just going to overburden. You have to watch two classes again just to revise it.
Monal S: Okay? So, if only you have the revised classes, objects, self.
Monal S: the whole understanding of memory and other things, why we are doing it, then stay for this class, I'll revise it, then once this recording is available, then watch it again. Yes?
Monal S: So… Again, why you have not done that?
Monal S: I always tell you to revise the… or I always tell everyone to revise these classes right here.
Monal S: I'm new student, I've completed Lecture 6. Shramid, welcome to this course, and if you don't know object-oriented programming, then this is going to be a super confusing class. So, make sure that you watch previous class, if you still understand functions, but you need to watch previous class.
Monal S: If you understand objectivity programming, then feel free to stay. Else, it is just going to waste your time, make you more…
Monal S: what should I do? Uncomfortable with all this coding. So, that's that.
Monal S: Chantnam was that assignment, okay? I've also given the solution. I've written the solution.
Monal S: Okay? Is everyone able to understand the expectation of today's class? Guys, this is not just like our traditional class which we are following, where we are variable, tomorrow we are going to learn loops. No. This is a series, and if you don't know the day one of series, day two is going to be very hectic.
Monal S: Are we clear? Say yes or no in the chat, everyone. Is my voice clear? Is my audio clear?
Monal S: Prince, you can.
Monal S: UK. Okay?
Monal S: That will be today, Karthik. Okay, audio's clear? Yes, guys, I figured out one issue. I think that was because of my hardware Wi-Fi. So today, I installed a new
Monal S: USB adapter. So, it looks like it is working. From the morning I was doing it.
Monal S: Figuring out the issue, but now it is good. So let's see, let's see in this class. If something goes wrong in between, make sure to join again, because I'm having some issue with my hardware. Only if something happens. Tomorrow, today it is not supposed to happen, but let's see again, okay? Alright, yes.
Monal S: Great for it.
Monal S: Guys, let's, coupon, let's not talk about coupon, okay? Coupon, I already said, everyone is also saying the same in the community, okay? Is everyone ready for today's class?
Monal S: Everyone?
Monal S: Are you guys ready for today's class? Yes. And guys, trust me,
Monal S: Have your coffee alongside this class, because this is going to be…
Monal S: complex, because as I already told you, right, this is an intermediate class. So let me disable the chat. Not disabled. First, let me ask you a few things. How many of you remember it?
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: I hope my screen is visible.
Monal S: Guys, let's not bring any other programming language now, okay?
Monal S: Thank you.
Monal S: Alright, so today is… 7… 2… what am I writing?
Monal S: 2026.
Monal S: Visible?
Monal S: Okay. Agenda.
Monal S: What is today's agenda, guys? Tell me today's agenda. Just wanted to check. Aval, good morning.
Monal S: I just wanted to check how many of you remember, how many of you looks at email subject, or… yes, oops, continuation, object-oriented programming 2.
Monal S: plus… modules.
Monal S: Okay? We will focus majorly here, because this is where the overwhelming part is, but I will make sure that people who does not
Monal S: In the previous iterations of their understanding of, oops, not my class, but in previous, like, college or something, or sometime, if they don't understand it, 100% you will understand all those concepts today.
Monal S: And modules, and…
Monal S: Yeah, modules is something which we will cover next. Okay? Good morning, guys. Good morning. Okay? So, in object-oriented programming, now we are going to cover four pillars of object-oriented programming, but first, let me write whatever things which we have known. So, guys, I'm going to disable the chat, is that fine? Yes?
Monal S: Done? Alright, thank you.
Monal S: Great, awesome.
Monal S: Done. My chat is disabled, okay? So… yes.
Monal S: Object-oriented programming.
Monal S: object-oriented programming class, too. So, in the previous class, we have seen that our procedural programming works from top to bottom, but not every time we want to have that approach. Also, the major issue was our function and data were a different entity. So, if they want to share a same memory, we have to use global in a lot of places. They're not bound, and it is not really a good
Monal S: experience for programming, right? We require a better standardized way. So there, we used object-oriented programming, where we have
Monal S: class, that is the blueprint, and then we create the instance. I hope everyone knows what do we mean by creating an object? It means initializing all the required available memory requirement for that particular blueprint, and that we call it as an instance, okay?
Monal S: So, instance is where it exists in the RAM. So, this is instance, this is just blueprint. So, from the same blueprint, we can create
Monal S: many objects we like. So, blueprint, and then this is our object. And from the same blueprint, we can create multiples. This is what object is.
Monal S: And, we have also seen a few important things like constructor in the class, right? We also have constructor.
Monal S: Okay, and constructor is the first method which runs when we create an object. This is an optional, this is not at all required, but it is very, very, very useful when we want to initialize some variables, which we are going to use later, like your name, your balance, we'll talk about more, okay? We'll talk about more.
Monal S: And then we have also seen one very important attribute of classes, and in their blueprint, they should have a common connection. Common connection is not a technical word, but we have used common connection
Monal S: We have used Common Connection, 2… refer…
Monal S: the self. Self is also not a name, but we are just typing, we are just writing a name self, which is shared between all the methods of a class, which forms a common connection, which helps class to tell that this is my variable, this is my method, this is my other method, whatever it is.
Monal S: Whatever is shared for that particular class, we write with the help of cells, alright? This is what we have learned till now, okay? So, in this class, what we're going to talk about, we are going to keep this foundation, guys. This foundation is required, this foundation is going to go till the end of the programming, okay? We will be seeing this foundation everywhere. But now, let's talk about
Monal S: more ways to create better code, okay? How can we provide security? How can we provide reusable code? How can we create contract kind of thing from the classes? We'll talk about each and everything, and these are called as four pillars of object-oriented programming, okay? Four…
Monal S: pillars of… Object-oriented programming.
Monal S: Well, again, the pillars is not a concept, the concept is object-oriented programming has four different concepts that we need to learn, okay? Let me write some of them, and then I will explain it, they will do the coding and complete one by one, okay?
Monal S: Next. Where is it? Yes, here it is. So…
Monal S: The first concept that we need to learn
Monal S: The first concept that we need to learn is called as encapsulation.
Monal S: This is a concept name, and guys, whatever I'm teaching today, all of them is very, very, very important for interview question. This is what they ask in object-oriented programming, along with self, and what is a constructor, why it is used, and other things. But everything that is a concept part is a part of internal, okay? So, encapsulation is used for data…
Monal S: Hi, Eddie.
Monal S: In this particular concept, we are going to learn that what method, what method, what data we want to hide from user, it's kind of like providing security. What user can access, what we want user to have, what things they can use it in our class, okay? So, we will talk about that here. Also, before talking about this encapsulation, I will talk about
Monal S: scope of… we already know a scope of a variable, right? An all-on variable versus a global. So, local versus global variable. Here, we will talk about more scopes, but with respect to classes. So, things are going to change, and we will see practical of each and everything. That is about encapsulation, okay?
Monal S: I'm just doing a high-level overview, this helps us understand what is the agenda of today's class. And then the next is abstraction.
Monal S: Okay? Abstraction is, from my understanding, okay? You will find a lot of different jargons on internet, which will help, which will make you, like, what is actually an abstraction? If you just search on Google, Google will say abstraction is complexity reduction.
Monal S: complexity reduction, okay? But this kind of a definition kind of confuses us, so what I'm going to do, I'm going to write my own definition, that is, it kind of creates a contract.
Monal S: Okay? Contract. So, whatever we have written in this contract, we have to follow that. So, we create a contract in abstraction, and then we follow it. How do we create it? How do we follow it is what we are going to learn, okay? So, this is contract. And…
Monal S: We also say it as hiding complex implementation.
Monal S: Well, this hiding complex implementation is a part of object-oriented programming itself, but make sure that you understand contract. If you know contract, if you know data hiding, you will be able to understand their actual meanings, encapsulation and abstraction.
Monal S: So let me write, whatever you guys have to remember, I'm going to mark it as this color, okay? Data hiding, contract, scope. Don't worry about hiding complex implementation, just fancy stuff.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Next is inheritance.
Monal S: We know what is inheritance in the real world. We get something from our parents, parents get something from their parents, we are inheriting something. That is the same concept we tried to bring in Python, using inheritance, but it is used here for code reuse.
Monal S: Code reuse. Very interesting concept, and very, very, very useful. All the things that we are going to learn, okay, let me get there a little bit later, but we'll talk about it. Okay, this is the inheritance code reuse, okay?
Monal S: Final thing is polymorphism, which is the most confusing one, but it will not be confusing in today's class, okay?
Monal S: Polymorphism. It means the… this term itself means it has many forms.
Monal S: Okay? Again, this will confuse you, why it is a many form, okay? Why it is many forms. But, when I will talk about what exactly is many forms, why polymorphism is used, then that part will be clear, okay? So, I cannot write in short, but here, understand that it is many forms, okay?
Monal S: Or, let me just write… Better word…
Monal S: Ability of different object to respond in a similar way, okay?
Monal S: to respond And, similar way.
Monal S: Okay? If you remember this, then you understand polymorphism, okay? Ability of different objects to respond in a similar way, okay? So, what we need to remember here? We need to remember code reuse, and then this particular line, if you guys can remember, then it will.
Monal S: be better, okay? So, is everyone clear on a high-level overview the four pillars of object-oriented programming, even though we don't know the actual meaning, but this is what we are going to do. These are the four pillars. And guys, make sure that you
Monal S: Don't… don't do coding alongside with me. That really distracts. I see some people in the community that ask that, should I supposed to do coding? No. Don't do coding, coding you can do later. You have your whole life to do the coding, but concept is more only once. Okay, is everyone clear?
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Others… Awesome.
Monal S: Great.
Monal S: Okay, disabling the chat again, okay?
Monal S: Guys.
Monal S: attention spans drop, whatever. If you are losing the focus while coding, then don't do it. If it is making you more focus, then do it. But if you're… if I have already answered something, and you are doing coding, you forgot what I told you, then that is another issue that you have to worry about, okay?
Monal S: Yes. Okay.
Monal S: disabled, okay? Now, let's jump to the coding part, because this is where we are going to learn. Everyone is familiar with what this particular thing is. For people who joined you, if you don't know what we are doing here, you need to watch the classes again, okay?
Monal S: Because we have moved far.
Monal S: IPY and B, okay? This is where we will start. So first, I will start with the first topic that is encapsulation, the first pillar, okay? Object-generated programming, two.
Monal S: And… The first is… Inheritance. Not inheritance, encapsulation.
Monal S: Okay? The topic which we are learning is in calculation, but here, first, I will talk about scope levels in Python.
Monal S: scope levels in pipe, okay? This is what we are going to learn first. So, let me define a few of the scope that…
Monal S: First, let me define our class, okay? Let me define a class called as bank.
Monal S: bank account. Everyone knows that B should be capital.
Monal S: just for the better naming convention, okay? And here we have in it
Monal S: Let me zoom in better, okay? The first should be self. I want name of the customer, and I want what banners that they have, okay? And we know a few kind of variables. We know that, self.name, we can get from the name, right? This is
Monal S: just a simple variable. So, variable without any other characters, this is called as public. It means it is accessible to public as well. I will talk about it, okay? How to access this variable from the class itself.
Monal S: Second. Second type is called as protected, so let me write self. Let's suppose I want to know the account type. So, see this? If I add underscore at the start.
Monal S: only one underscore. This makes it as a protected. Later, you can type whatever variable name you want. Let's suppose I want to type account underscore type.
Monal S: So, any variable on the… in the class that starts with underscore, that starts with underscore, by default, has a different level of protection. This one, we will call it as savings. So, this particular account type is savings. User has not passed it, but we are storing it into the constructor. We are initializing it. Next type.
Monal S: First, let me write what this is called. This is called as protective.
Monal S: Okay? This is called as protected.
Monal S: Next, double underscore. When we write double underscore, this is called as private variable. This is private to the class. I will show you why creating the object, then you will understand what is accessible, what is not, okay? Let's suppose I want to write balance.
Monal S: And FedEx.
Monal S: That's right, this is private.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: So the only difference is… only difference between these multiple scopes of this variable is the public does not have any underscore at the start.
Monal S: Anything that starts with single underscore is by default protected. Anything that starts with double underscore is by default private.
Monal S: Okay? It's by default, private. So… Let me select the kernel.
Monal S: And then, let's create the bank account.
Monal S: Okay? I will say it as Bank Account 1. This is my object name, BA1.
Monal S: Okay. It is missing because we need to pass name, so let me pass the last person's name, it is Shramit.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: And let's add some money to Suramit account. Let's add…
Monal S: Let's make him rich, okay? Done.
Monal S: So, this is Shramid's account, and then this is object. As we know, this is object, it means
Monal S: Self is also holding the same address. So, object is also having the address, self is also having the same address. So, if I try to access this object and the variable directly, because all of them is a part of same connection, if I do…
Monal S: the object.name, I will be able to access what is the name of Sherman. Yes? What is the value inside this name variable? So I'm able to get Shermit. Now let's try to access next thing, that is account type.
Monal S: Again, I'm able to access. Here, I told you that it is protected, but why we are able to access? Well, whenever you use protected, you are telling other developers that you are not supposed to use outside. So, whenever you use protected.
Monal S: Okay? Let me just write. You will understand now.
Monal S: Whenever you use protected, this is just a warning to tell other… developers that…
Monal S: You should not use this variable. That…
Monal S: You should not use other developer.
Monal S: So it is just a way to tell, because when someone sees your code, they will see underscore, it means you should not do something like this. When you use this code in other place, you should not do something like this. But when a class is having this name, it means you're telling other developer that, feel free to use this. Similar like a concept of OTP.
Monal S: When you see OTP, when you are… when you get a SMS, when you get SMS from any provider, and that is OTP, your system automatically says that, don't share this OTP, you are able to copy or something, yes? You are able to copy or something. So, what they are doing, they are just doing by the name of OTP. So, similar kind of concept is here. You are telling other developer that
Monal S: When we don't have underscore, feel free to use it outside. But when you have one single underscore, please don't use it. So this is kind of a request to other developer, that's just a warning to tell other developer that you should not use it, okay?
Monal S: You should not use it, use it outside.
Monal S: Okay? So, this kind of thing, particularly, I don't use, but let's talk about this double underscore. So, I have BA underscore 1, and I want to get the balance.
Monal S: This one will say that it does not even have an attribute, it does not even have underscore, underscore balance. It means outside of class, outside of class, we are not able to access this.
Monal S: Okay? We are not able to access it. So let me write a few information about the public. This is encapsulation. Here, I will write about public.
Monal S: where we can access it. Public, we can access it anywhere.
Monal S: Okay? Public, we can access it anywhere. Syntax, let me write syntax.
Monal S: Holy Later.
Monal S: This is not a dictionary, but I'm just writing it. So… syntax.
Monal S: What is the syntax? Just simple name.
Monal S: What is the access?
Monal S: Access we can do anywhere.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: This is about public. Now, let's talk about protected.
Monal S: Let's talk about protected. The syntax is underscore name, accesses, you can access in class, plus you can access in child classes.
Monal S: Don't worry, we will understand what do we mean by child classes. It is a concept of inheritance, but there you will see more, okay? Now, let's talk about the final thing that is private.
Monal S: It starts with double underscore, then whatever the name is, and it can only be accessed Only… inside… class.
Monal S: Okay? It can only be used inside the class, okay?
Monal S: So, protected, again, I'm telling… protected, again, we are able to access, but protected… we are saying that we should… we should use it in class and child classes, but it does not restrict us to use outside the class as well, okay? So, it is not restricted, it is just a warning. Keep this in mind, I am telling you again, it does not restrict you to use outside, it just gives you a warning.
Monal S: If you want a really high-end protection, then use double underscore, which is a private. Now, if private we are not able to access, then how can we access?
Monal S: Here, I have mentioned that only inside class. It means this balance, I'm able to initialize. I have the balance, but I need some way to access the balance. So now comes a concept of getter and setter. It is not a concept, it is just in programming, we use these words to define a category of function.
Monal S: Okay? So, let me write function category.
Monal S: category of functions or methods. Now, I don't have to tell you difference between function and methods.
Monal S: I'm using it interchangeably because now we know what the difference is.
Monal S: So, when we work with any kind of a function in object-oriented programming, we kind of want to give two different kinds of methods, okay? There are other kinds, that is, we are fine to write our logic, that is fine.
Monal S: But…
Monal S: One of them is called as getter. So, getter are functions which is used to get values from something, okay?
Monal S: get values. Very simple. It is not a concept, you don't have to write any fancy function, I will tell you. Then we have setter.
Monal S: These are functions which set the value.
Monal S: Set values.
Monal S: Okay? So, if you add these two functions to your class, that will make it as a better, overall blueprint. Suppose you have a bank, right? You have a bank. In every bank, you will be able to see that deposit.
Monal S: You have a deposit button, you also have view balance.
Monal S: So, think of deposit as… think of deposit as a setup. You are able to set… you are able to set new values
Monal S: And what about view balance?
Monal S: What about view balance? View balance is in Canada.
Monal S: As I told you, this is not at all a new function, so see what I'm doing. Just a naming convent… not even a naming convention, I'm just going to write.
Monal S: BEF… get balance. You can write whatever you want.
Monal S: You can write whatever you want, but I'm using it, and just let me just write, I'm just using it to get…
Monal S: Value of the… balance variable.
Monal S: Okay? What I will do, I will print… I will print.
Monal S: Your current balance.
Monal S: is self.balance, okay? So now, see this. I am using self.underscore underscore balance
Monal S: inside the class attribute, inside the class method, I am not letting anyone to use it outside the class. Only when I call, only when I call this object BA1,
Monal S: dot getBalance.
Monal S: And this function, which is a part of class itself, connected by a cell, has access to self-balance, because we know only inside the class we can access it. So, let's see this now.
Monal S: I have created bank balance.
Monal S: added, 1 lakh rupees here, okay? Then, I'm able to access name, I'm able to access account name, account type, but I'm not able to access parent. Same as before. But now, I am giving user a functionality. Only if you use this function.
Monal S: Only if you use this function, you will be able to get the balance. I'm not giving you any other points. Only if you use this button, you will know what is your current balance.
Monal S: So, we are giving user, we as a developer has the control that we want user to see, but user does not have control over the object.
Monal S: We, as a developer, are giving them.
Monal S: User does not have access.
Monal S: Next.
Monal S: Because that is, I told you, this is a type of getter. So, guys, getter is just a concept. It means we want to write a function which helps us retrieve values. Now, let's do one more thing. This is getBalance. Now, let's also create setBalance.
Monal S: Set balance. What this will do, if I have to set balance I will say…
Monal S: let's say, add balance. It means we want to access it and set a new balance, okay? Let me write add and
Monal S: set… New Balance.
Monal S: I know this is a very big function name, but it tells us what we are trying to do. Setter. So, this one, we will use it for…
Monal S: To set the… to add…
Monal S: What? To deposit?
Monal S: To deposit money in our account.
Monal S: Okay? And if you want to deposit what we need, we also want user to provide what amount you want to add. So user will pass the amount, then what we will do? What we will do? In self.balance, we just need to add… we just need to add that amount.
Monal S: And that amount will be reflected here. Done. So, add and set new balance. Using… only using this method, user cannot directly access balance and say, I want 2 left here. I want…
Monal S: User cannot say that I want to here. User once initialized with the name and the balance at the start, user cannot change the balance, because it is
Monal S: not even accessible outside, user cannot do that. So, if user want to add something, they can only add via method we as a developer are
Monal S: are trying to give back, okay? Let's run it again. Everything will run, get balance is run. Now.
Monal S: Let's add some value.
Monal S: Let's see whether we are able to add any value.
Monal S: Let's see, okay? See, we are able to set the value for some reason.
Monal S: Let me just check, okay?
Monal S: What is the balance mark? If it works, see, something happened here. We are not able to access it, but we are able to overwrite it.
Monal S: variable I was using.
Monal S: Just wait, okay?
Monal S: Good.
Monal S: So…
Monal S: If we don't want user to override, then what we should do? Let me just check it, okay? Because we are able to override, but not access. But this should not happen, but it is letting us do that, okay? It is letting us do that. So what we should do…
Monal S: Just give me a second, okay?
Monal S: Okay, got it.
Monal S: Okay, see this. There is another method that we need to use for now, but
Monal S: Let's not use it, because that is going to create an issue, okay? That is going to create an issue. But we have seen one, issue here that we are not tri- we are not able to access, but for some reason, Python is giving us way to edit it, right? That is totally weird.
Monal S: But if I say… say this, but if I write something like this…
Monal S: Okay, if I write something like this, that is… property.
Monal S: Okay? Then let's try to do it.
Monal S: Where is that property?
Monal S: We only want to use it Looks weird, like, second.
Monal S: What is going on?
Monal S: Just wait, guys, okay? This should not happen…
Monal S: That's right.
Monal S: Okay, this is how we learn behavior that we are not supposed to do. We are able to
Monal S: Do it, right?
Monal S: I'm just checking that what exactly…
Monal S: Okay, okay, wait, wait. Now I'm able to understand, okay? So, there is another concept that comes here.
Monal S: Okay, see this. It is not actually creating it, but this is a very weird thing. If I run this function, are we able to see the same thing again?
Monal S: It is not… this variable itself is overriding, but are we able to see the old value?
Monal S: even though I changed this value here, but when I run this getBalance, which is trying to access this value, that's why it is creating an issue for me, okay? So, when I try to run this function, let's run it again.
Monal S: Okay, I added this new value, Python told me, yes, I accept it. When I printed it, Python is telling me, yes, I'm able to give you this number. But when I'm trying to use the get balance, when I'm trying to use the get balance and access this value, it is still telling me that the private variable value is still
Monal S: It is still this value.
Monal S: Okay? It means it is not changing this value, but it is change… but it is adding a new variable inside, a public variable called like this. Okay? When we do something like this, it actually creates a variable like this. Just wait.
Monal S: How should I write this variable?
Monal S: Yeah.
Monal S: it adds a new variable with the class name. What is the class name? What is the class name? Bank account.
Monal S: So, it internally creates a variable like this.
Monal S: A public variable.
Monal S: So, it is not really editing the private, but Python, whenever it sees it… now, let me introduce. See what happened here.
Monal S: Very interesting thing, guys.
Monal S: So it is not breaking the Python, but Python works in mysterious ways.
Monal S: Okay, everyone, please focus your class here, okay?
Monal S: People will not even ask this in an interview, okay? So, when I did… When I did bank account.
Monal S: when I did bank account and pass name of A with some values.
Monal S: let's say 100, okay? With some values, Hendrace. I got an object of OB1. This is my object.
Monal S: As I told you, this is private, it means we cannot access it, we cannot edit it. That is still true. Private, we cannot access.
Monal S: We cannot edit outside.
Monal S: We cannot edit outside the class, okay? We cannot edit, we cannot access outside the class. So, when I'm trying to use getBalance.
Monal S: when I'm trying to use getBalance, and this particular method itself is trying to show us what is the private variable value. So, getBalance will give us the current value is 100.
Monal S: This part is clear, everyone.
Monal S: Everyone, this part is clear.
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Guys, this part, only these two lines, only these two lines is clear.
Monal S: Okay? Okay.
Monal S: Guys, a little fast, this is what we have learned till now. I'm not teaching anything.
Monal S: Guys, only I told you two lines. We created the object, this is our object. When I do obe1.getBalance, I will get 100. Is this two lines clear?
Monal S: Is this two lines clear?
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Okay, now see this behavior. Yes, now see this behavior. Any private variable, let me write this concept, which will help you.
Monal S: Any private Any private variable.
Monal S: Okay? Any private variable…
Monal S: Python renames to… yes, Python… Renames to… underscore… class name.
Monal S: Underscore, underscore, the private variable name.
Monal S: The private variable name.
Monal S: Is this part you were able to understand?
Monal S: Guys, any private variable, when we write in any private variable, when we write it, Python renames internally to this particular name.
Monal S: Is this part clear? This particular concept is called as name mangling.
Monal S: This concept itself is called as name… Mangley.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: Guys, when you write, see this, again, I'm telling, when you write, self.underscore underscore A. This is what
Monal S: Guys, everyone tell me, this is what kind of a variable, this is what kind of a variable.
Monal S: People are saying protected.
Monal S: Private.
Monal S: You have written this. Python will internally rename it to, if class name is called as… Hello, capital S-E-L-L-O.
Monal S: If class name is capital hello, we have self underscore underscore A, Python will internally rename.
Monal S: Python will internally rename it to underscore Hello, underscore, underscore T.
Monal S: to make it a real private variable. This happens inside.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: So whatever variable we make into a private, Python will make it like this.
Monal S: Again, are we clear?
Monal S: Everyone… now see this, why it happened, why this weird code behavior happened, okay? That we are able to edit the values. How can we edit the values?
Monal S: How can we edit the values? Now see.
Monal S: We have Obi-Wan.
Monal S: When we try to access… everyone see this?
Monal S: Yes. When we try to access OB1.underscore underscore balance.
Monal S: When we try to access this, Python is telling us, error.
Monal S: Python is telling us error.
Monal S: Python is saying that this does not exist.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: That's true.
Monal S: Is this variable exists, or the name itself is different?
Monal S: When we created the object, does Python has this variable now? Does Python has this variable now, or it has something else?
Monal S: Does Python has this variable, or this variable?
Monal S: Everyone, Python has something else. So when we try to access this, Python, say, I don't know this.
Monal S: Is this the correct error we are getting, guys?
Monal S: Python saying, I don't have underscore, underscore balance, is this correct?
Monal S: That's why we were getting it.
Monal S: Okay? But… From the conclusion… Only when we have object, what should I write here to access it?
Monal S: What should I write here to access it?
Monal S: What is the class name?
Monal S: Bangal.
Monal S: Underscore bank account underscore underscore.
Monal S: account type.
Monal S: Not account type. What was that value guys? It is balance only, right? Yes, balance.
Monal S: balance. Let's try to access now.
Monal S: This one, when I try to do it… let me run everything again, run it again, run it again, name, account type we are able to access. This is giving an error. When I run it, will I be able to access it?
Monal S: If I run it, will I be able to access it? Yes.
Monal S: This is a weird thing, in Java, it will never happen, but in Python, it will happen.
Monal S: Are we able to access it?
Monal S: Are we able to access it? Yeah, nearby. This should not happen, but in Java, they don't allow it. In Python, they allow it, okay?
Monal S: Guys, did I give 20,000? Don't look at the previous code. Everyone, this is the code I initialized with Shramit, and 100,000.
Monal S: Name is from it. Account type is savings. Balance is not accessible because… balance is not accessible because? Balance does not even exist.
Monal S: But Python made it like this. So, it is… See that, Ram? Yes.
Monal S: So it is accessible.
Monal S: Next, when I try to get the balance, Python is not trying to access underscore underscore balance, but Python is internally looking at underscore balance. Are we able to get that?
Monal S: Are we able to get that?
Monal S: Yes. Now… Where I initialize this value, does this value exist?
Monal S: When I initialize this value, does this variable even exist?
Monal S: Does this variable even exist? No. So what Python will do in this particular case…
Monal S: Excite?
Monal S: What Python will do when we write OB1.underscore underscore balance
Monal S: When we write even 200, what Python will try to do?
Monal S: What Python will try to do?
Monal S: It will create… new variable.
Monal S: Because it is creating a new variable, it is creating a new variable.
Monal S: And it will assign a value of 200. So, underscore, underscore violence will be a variable which will not be private, okay? Because Python is creating it. We are not created inside it. We have not created this inside.
Monal S: Okay? This will be a separate balance, and this will be a separate balance with the class name underscore. So, this is different, okay? So, when I'm trying to do this, see this? When I'm trying to do the balance, a new balance, Python told me done.
Monal S: Python told me, done. We created new balance. When we tried to access it, Python told me, yes, you can access it, because this exists. But when we do get balance, it will try to access what?
Monal S: But when we do get balance, it will try to access what?
Monal S: GetBalance is using… This variable internally.
Monal S: Okay? It is not really that secure here, but when we try to learn, more things in Python, there is a concept of decorator called as property, which will help us do this.
Monal S: Okay? Which will help us do this.
Monal S: Is everyone clear with how Python works?
Monal S: Okay? So… 2… Restrict.
Monal S: Everyone, write in your notes to restrict the variable from getting Updated by a new value.
Monal S: We will later… Learn a concept, called as…
Monal S: property decorator. So, guys, this is, again, a very important interview question. People can trick you that, can you edit Python private variables? What is the answer?
Monal S: Can you edit Python private variables? What is the answer?
Monal S: Yes!
Monal S: Guys, we were able to. See this?
Monal S: Are we not able to edit the values?
Monal S: I can also edit this value.
Monal S: I'm not able to edit this value, but I can edit this value.
Monal S: Let's check the balance.
Monal S: So Python creates these blocks of data to tell us that what is private, what is protected. I can give you some error if you try to access outside, but if you use it from the full name, I can give you access. Weird.
Monal S: Is this part weird? People coming from Java will find it very weird.
Monal S: Okay? So, think of it as, like, even though it is giving you
Monal S: Even though it is giving you public… Protected.
Monal S: and private.
Monal S: We can access all… If we know workaround.
Monal S: Okay? If we know, workaround.
Monal S: If we want real security.
Monal S: We need to use…
Monal S: property decorator, okay? We need to use property decorator.
Monal S: Getter and Setter.
Monal S: Vid?
Monal S: this… private scopes.
Monal S: We need to use private scopes with property getter and setter, then only we can do this.
Monal S: Is this concept clear?
Monal S: So, guys…
Monal S: Public is, we can access anywhere. Protected is, we can still access. Private is, we can access only from inside, but if we want, if we use the full name, we can again access it anywhere.
Monal S: But if you want to use the same name of balance, then it is accessible only from the methods inside.
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Privates, if you want to use underscore, underscore balance to update the value, then you can use it.
Monal S: Real users will… person who is using your application, guys, okay? See this?
Monal S: Person who is using your application.
Monal S: Will only have… will only have object, or will only have buttons.
Monal S: They will never know what is the class name.
Monal S: They will not know the class name. If you don't know the class name, will you be able to update from the outside?
Monal S: will you be able to update from the outside? No. So this is kind of a very mild version of security, but to have the real version of security. How many of you know now the workaround?
Monal S: Abjit, I told you, right? What is the solution? How many of you know the workaround of accessing private outside, using it as a public?
Monal S: Guess?
Monal S: Tanme, I told you, anything that is an underscore, underscore name, I can… I cannot use underscore, underscore, balance, and access outside.
Monal S: This underscore underscore balance can only be used inside another method.
Monal S: But that, if you know the workaround, that is, if you know the class name and then the variable, then you can also use it outside as well.
Monal S: Okay? So, this particular encapsulation, the scope levels which we did, this is scope levels of public
Monal S: Protected and private.
Monal S: assumes… the… developer responsible. The…
Monal S: Okay? The developer is responsible. Okay? This is just different levels of security, that's all. Different level of access, that's all.
Monal S: Are you clear?
Monal S: in Java, Java will not let this set.
Monal S: Java will… Create an error.
Monal S: Okay, Java will create an error.
Monal S: So this is like… Consent.
Monal S: Are we clear with this topic, guys?
Monal S: Are we clear with this topic?
Monal S: Can I see the code? Guys, see the code. Okay? It is a little confusing, but this confusing part is something which you need to remember about Python.
Monal S: Guys, this confusing part is something that you need to remember about Python.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Guys, I told you every other way to check the value.
Monal S: This is how we can check the value. This is how we can check the value. So this is just a consent part.
Monal S: Guys, everyone know what is the… Yes, what is the rectification? Sign?
Monal S: Yes, that is true. But if I tell it now, everyone will be confused.
Monal S: What is the scope of B underscore balance? Guys, I told you the scope is private.
Monal S: The scope is private.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Python is getting interesting. Okay. Guys, I am revising it again because people are asking the same thing, disable the chat. Done.
Monal S: See this. What I did, I created a bank account within it, self-name, this one is protected, this one is underscore, underscore balance.
Monal S: So this is all the things which we're able to see is only for us developers to not do weird things, okay? To not do weird things. It does not provide security on the outside level, but it provides a way for you to write secure code, or at least
Monal S: way to tell other developers that what we want, okay? Because if I write everything with name, account name, and balance, developers will not know that this one is require more private thing, this one will require more catering, this one will require public-level catering.
Monal S: Okay? So just for developers to know, if everything is this, how develop… and I have 50 more variables.
Monal S: Our developer, other developers who are going to work is going to add more security. They will never know. But if you add this, at least on the developer level, we know what is going on. This is public protected balance.
Monal S: Public says that you can access it anywhere outside the class as well. We know that is true for all the cases, but on a high-level overview, Protector says that whenever you mention underscore name, we are only supposed to use it inside class and child classes.
Monal S: Private is not even child classes, but only inside classes you are supposed to use it.
Monal S: Okay? Only inside class, you are supposed to use it. So the word I'm saying is supposed to use it, okay? This is a very weird topic in Python. Java knows that it will not allow all of this, but in Python, that you have to remember this. This is the interview question. That weird behavior itself is the interview question.
Monal S: So, public protected, and private.
Monal S: assumes all of… whatever we are writing is the developer's responsibility. It is just kind of a consent that
Monal S: I'm saving someone password in private, I'm saving someone identity ID in protected, and public things in public, okay? So developers who are going to use this code to make it more secure is going to work on those variables to make it more secure, that we are going to learn later.
Monal S: Now, this bank account we are initializing with name and balance, this name will go here, balance will go here. So, just this exact name, we will not be able to access it outside because it does not exist. Python will convert this private to
Monal S: underscore bank account underscore underscore balance. So, this variable technically does not exist when we create an object out of it, but…
Monal S: This unders… this, this variable that we will use, anywhere we will refer to set this value inside the class, will know its full name.
Monal S: So, self underscore balance can be updated inside the class method, and it will be correct. Okay? It will be correct. So, bank account, I've created the name and the value, this is object.
Monal S: I'm able to access name, I'm also able to access protected. I am not able to access underscore underscore balance, because Python converted it to the full name. This is not the full name.
Monal S: It is saying that it does not exist.
Monal S: Now, if I try to access the full name, I'm able to access, but I need to know the class name and the private variable name, okay? So, that is the next part. Second is, get balance.
Monal S: GetBalance will use the Python internal private variable, self.balance. It will check its full name and update the amount there, only on the full name, okay? And then it will update the… and then it will get us the balance. So that is getBalance. Current balance is… this.
Monal S: Now, when I try to update this balance variable, which I know exists inside the object, it will update it. But we all know that inside the object, this is not the full name. So, when we try to do this using data mangling.
Monal S: Okay? Using name mangling, using name mangling, Python will create a new variable, because this variable does not exist, it will create a new variable with underscore, underscore balance, and then it will save that value. So self.underscore underscore balance is not changed, this new variable got created.
Monal S: And, this value. If we want to update the original private underscore underscore balance, the original name is underscore bank account underscore underscore balance equals to 100.
Monal S: And then, if we try to access the balance, balance is the same value. If you try to access the bank balance.
Monal S: Which is, the getBalance will use that variable, we will see the new end right here. Okay? And to provide more security, it is in upcoming classes.
Monal S: Okay? So is everyone clear with this review, this super confusing part, super weird part? It is not confusing, it is weird.
Monal S: Is everyone clear? Is everyone agrees that it is not confusing, it is weird.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Okay? So make sure that you remember this. Super weird. Yes, a programming language should not does it, but Python, because of inheritance classes, it is doing that, okay?
Monal S: Is it…
Monal S: Just wanted to check one more thing.
Monal S: Just wait, okay?
Monal S: Guys, let's not talk about… this is not related to real world, this is related to programming. For now, we are not going to the real world part.
Monal S: Okay? We are not going into the real-world part.
Monal S: And guys, when I do this, Python will create what? Tell me, when I do this, what will be the scope of this variable?
Monal S: Will it be private, or will it be public? Python create this as a public.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: No, not private. See, name manually is a concept, okay? It tells you the behavior of that name, what will happen to them.
Monal S: But it starts with at least two underscores, okay? So that part is only for Private Navid.
Monal S: It is, at least unders… two underscores, it is for private only.
Monal S: private and others.
Monal S: Okay? So, this is how Python will do it, everyone. Python will internally, whenever you create a class, whenever you create a class.
Monal S: Whenever you create a class, Python will allocate what should be private, what should be public.
Monal S: and what should be protected, okay? If we do underscore, underscore balance, which does not exist.
Monal S: Python will see that we are the one creating it, it will put into the public. If Python will say A equals to 20, it is already public. If Python will see inside the object, we initialize something like underscore underscore balance.
Monal S: This is something we created inside the object it will put into the private. So this is how Python will kind of track it.
Monal S: Okay? Are we clear? This is how Python will track it.
Monal S: palpage… Name manglis is applied to variables with double underscore. Are you clear?
Monal S: Hi, everyone?
Monal S: Done. So let's not worry about this variable. We are here to understand. So this is the first part of abstraction, but abstraction we will learn more in what class, guys? This encapsulation. This encapsulation, we will learn more at…
Monal S: How to more… add more security in?
Monal S: How to add more security in?
Monal S: the property decorator getter, and setter. Is this part clear when we are going to learn it?
Monal S: Is this part clear to everyone? So, security part, let's move it. Let's not worry about the security part. Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Are we good with skipping security for now, but are we at least able to understand, from the consent and responsibility point of view, what is an encapsulation? Encapsulation is meant to hide the data.
Monal S: I know there are ways to, look at the data, but encapsulation is meant for hiding the data. That is the main concept, okay? Now let's talk about the next part, then we will go on break. After the next part, we will go on break.
Monal S: Okay? Agar's not now.
Monal S: Not now.
Monal S: Now, let's… Move to the next part.
Monal S: In analytics.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: So, what inheritance does… See, everyone?
Monal S: Raveen, later, not now. This one, you will not be able to understand, but next, guys, encapsulation use case right now. How many of you are not able to understand the use case?
Monal S: Even though this one is not letting us do the security, but what is the use case?
Monal S: The use case is not let user get access to the data.
Monal S: not let user get access to the data or update the data. That is the concept encapsulation introduced on a high-level overview, not in an internal overview. In an internal level, we'll be using more things to make it more secure.
Monal S: So, what is the use case?
Monal S: Are we not learning the use case? I'm talking about others.
Monal S: What is the use case, everyone?
Monal S: with them, protected… again, everything in Python is kind of funny, okay? We are supposed to
Monal S: Okay? In calculation.
Monal S: The score plus control.
Monal S: This is what we will learn, okay? Keep funny things aside, how Python works, but that is the main part which you have to do. So, if someone gives you a class.
Monal S: Once we learn property decorators, once we learn property decorators.
Monal S: And they want you to encapsulate the class. Your task is to encapsulate the task.
Monal S: encapsulate the class. What you will do?
Monal S: You will add the
Monal S: Security to, not to… so that users will not get the data, using some unauthorized channel, and not share the data using unauthorized channel.
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: That is how we will do it, okay?
Monal S: Guys, real world is programming. Concept does not create real world. Concept creates a way to create better software, okay? So, now let's talk about inheritance.
Monal S: Okay. Inheritance allows a class to reuse to reuse… properties, To reuse properties and… Methods of another class.
Monal S: Okay? Very, very, very important. Okay? So, let me write it.
Monal S: What is the next topic?
Monal S: inheritance.
Monal S: So, inheritance tells that Abstraction? Guys, later, after inheritance, because abstraction uses inheritance, move on.
Monal S: Say this.
Monal S: Disabling the job.
Monal S: Class A… Class A has some properties called as A1, A2… E3.
Monal S: This is Class B.
Monal S: Class B has P1.
Monal S: and beta.
Monal S: Similarly, This is your parent.
Monal S: And this is you, child.
Monal S: They are checked.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Child to this parent.
Monal S: So, normally what happens, child inherits property of parents, okay? Property does not mean physical world property. Property also means attribute of the parents. If the parent has
Monal S: blue eyes, both the parents have blue eyes, the chances of inheriting it will also be higher in the child. And, their hair.
Monal S: Skin color, etc. You will inherit from.
Monal S: You will inherit from your parent, right?
Monal S: You will inherit from your parent. Inherit.
Monal S: This is the same concept.
Monal S: This is the same…
Monal S: concept in programming. This is Class B. Class B has property of B1 and B2, its own properties. Now, if class B wants to reuse the code which is already written in some other class, this Class B will inherit the properties of A, so Class B will now have
Monal S: A1, A2, A3, B1, and B2. It will have its own properties, also it will have its parent properties.
Monal S: Okay? So, this will be the properties of… the new?
Monal S: Class B.
Monal S: new classmate. Don't worry, I will answer everything, okay? I will answer everything how to do it. But first, we need to revise some theory.
Monal S: So, this is called as… Python inheritance support. How much, yeah, types of inheritance in Python?
Monal S: types of… inheritance. Don't worry, I will talk about the use case.
Monal S: So… This is called as single inheritance, okay? Single inheritance where class A is inheriting from Class B.
Monal S: Class A is inheriting from Class B.
Monal S: Okay? A from B. Second, this is called as multi-level.
Monal S: class A… is inheriting from Class B
Monal S: is generating from Class C. Or, if you want to write it better, I will just write it like this, to better understand, because arrows sometimes can be confusing. I can write arrow however I want, but this is what I'm writing.
Monal S: If there is a Class B child.
Monal S: And this is a parent, so… I'm just writing P.
Monal S: Okay, guys?
Monal S: Okay, I think this will confuse a lot of you. Child?
Monal S: And parent.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: If child is inheriting properties from…
Monal S: child is inheriting properties from parent, single. This is called a single inheritance. Similarly.
Monal S: Next.
Monal S: Multi-level.
Monal S: Child inherits property from a parent, If child has…
Monal S: Their… their children has more children.
Monal S: Their children has their own Okay. Then… They can inherit from.
Monal S: So, child is… child C is inheriting from their parent called as B, which has properties of A. So, C will have properties of both A and B.
Monal S: You're inheriting like this, one by one.
Monal S: Next.
Monal S: Multiple.
Monal S: Okay? Multiple.
Monal S: So… Child A, this is parent A plus parent B, both of their properties, both of their properties.
Monal S: A plus B, both of their properties is being inherited to C.
Monal S: So, here you are going into a different level, here you are checking multiple into single.
Monal S: Okay? Multiple into single.
Monal S: Is this part clear? Single, multiple, multi-level.
Monal S: Okay, this is the concept part. Both of the classes attribute get inheriting in the single time. Not in a level A to B, B to C, that is different, okay? So now, let's see.
Monal S: So, if I talk about a single property, I'm going to write the code for the same, okay? So, let's suppose, let me talk about a parent. There is a parent called as…
Monal S: class device.
Monal S: What are the basic attributes of any device? What are the basic attributes of any device?
Monal S: BF… Power on.
Monal S: Yes, any device should power on. I can write, print, device on.
Monal S: Yes? So this is one of my classes. Now, let's talk about actual devices. If I talk about
Monal S: class of TV.
Monal S: If I talk about class of TV.
Monal S: Now, TV should also turn on, TV should also, show. So, TV main property is…
Monal S: to visualization.
Monal S: Yes, it should run some movie, or let me just write… Play channels.
Monal S: Play channel.
Monal S: This is a property of TV.
Monal S: And then I will write a code for that.
Monal S: I will write a code for that, that, let's see, print play channel.
Monal S: But without power, will we be able to call play channel? I'm talking about real world.
Monal S: If TV has only play channel without an ability to turn, power on the TV, will we even able to do that? No.
Monal S: So, TV also has power on requirement. Is this requirement already fulfilled? Is the power on requirement already fulfilled? Yes.
Monal S: TV has play channel, device has power on. Instead of writing power on.
Monal S: Instead of writing power on. See, if I have to write power on, then for class remote, for class AC, I always have to use power on.
Monal S: So, why not do that in one class, and then use its properties in multiple places? So, to do the inheritance, this is how we do it.
Monal S: N brackets, see this?
Monal S: In bracket, we write which class we want to inherit. We want to inherit device.
Monal S: And then… done.
Monal S: Once we do this, all the properties of device is also now accessible inside TV. Let me show this, then I will ask your…
Monal S: doubts. I will clear doubts, okay? So this time, I will just use a simple one.
Monal S: That is… from now on, this will not be confusing, okay? Only this part, security part, is a little confusing.
Monal S: a little weird, not confusing, okay? So I'm going to create class, and just let me write single inheritance.
Monal S: Okay, single inheritance. I will say class called as device.
Monal S: Not bracket. And then, this one only has power.
Monal S: And then submit.
Monal S: Then I will do print, I will say…
Monal S: Device on. This is class called as device.
Monal S: Now I want to create another class called as TV.
Monal S: two channels.
Monal S: 10 as 1… To… Eddie.
Monal S: Okay, just simple print statement.
Monal S: Now, these two classes are created, they are not connected. So, if I try to use…
Monal S: If I try to have an object of TV as a small TV1, TV underscore 1, and then I will try to call TV underscore 1 dot showchannels.
Monal S: Okay, I will try to call.
Monal S: Let me make it a little clearer, remove this, yeah.
Monal S: create an object, then do show channels, it is working. But when I try to access power on.
Monal S: It will not work.
Monal S: It is not even an attribute of a TV object. So what we will do in this case, we will inherit the device. Whatever the properties of device is will also now be available in TV.
Monal S: Now our TV can also turn on without having a functionality written inside a class. We are just utilizing it, someone else. We are utilizing someone else, yes. So guys, now I'm enabling. Is this part clear now? Is inheritance the first single inheritance is clear.
Monal S: Simple? Is this very simple?
Monal S: It is very simple, guys.
Monal S: Guys, can we create a class without init… can we create a class without init?
Monal S: Yes. In it, I told you in the previous class, it is an optional. It should be used, you as a developer should use it, because there will be a lot of things you need to initialize. It means you are planning ahead, okay? But you can use it without it as well. Disabling the chat, and let's move forward.
Monal S: Guys…
Monal S: We have… we don't need to initialize device, we only need to initialize TV, because TV has all the attribute of device, okay? Connected.
Monal S: Yes. So anything, anything that is having bracket, in the bracket, see this? This one does not have bracket.
Monal S: Normally, class does not have bracket. When it has bracket, it accepts other class for inheritance and other things, okay? Done. Okay? So now, if you want, now let's talk about multi-level. Let me copy the code.
Monal S: And, okay, one more thing I wanted to tell you, because there, I need to write a lot of unnecessary code sometimes. In Python, there is a keyword called as pass.
Monal S: Whenever Python, just like comment, when Python sees comment, Python will ignore the whole line, okay? Python will not even read it, but when Python will see pass.
Monal S: It will read the code and ignore it.
Monal S: Read… and ignore.
Monal S: Okay? It will read it and ignore it.
Monal S: Not even read the line.
Monal S: Ignore the line itself.
Monal S: Okay? So… how to use it? How to use it? Just wanted to tell you here, okay? Serious, if I just write a simple if statement, and let's suppose right now me as a developer is only working on
Monal S: me as a developer is only working on creating the structure, only creating the structure. So I have to write something. If I don't write something and directly create else, Python will say, what is this structure?
Monal S: It is creating an error, but when I write something, it is okay for Python.
Monal S: Yes, it is okay for Python to create the structure. Later I can write, later I can write my logic. But, to create this empty thing which does not do anything, print is kind of a big statement. Why to use this lengthy statement? So there comes the concept of pass.
Monal S: If we are not sure for now that what we want to do with it, we are just focusing on creating the actual structure, we write pass. So when we write pass, Python will read this line, it will not break the structure of if, because if requires something here.
Monal S: Yes? So, you can do it like this.
Monal S: Is everyone clear with PaaS?
Monal S: Guys… Very simple.
Monal S: So, whenever I feel like I don't have to write a lot of code, I'm going to introduce, guys. If I run it, no error.
Monal S: But if I remove it… It will say some structure is broken.
Monal S: Okay? So… guys… Pass means… nothing.
Monal S: Pass is same as… pass is same as…
Monal S: Just nothing. But in Python, just nothing is none. What do you mean by none? See this?
Monal S: We were able to do the same.
Monal S: But we have a special keyword which you can always use, which other developer will also know that when you write pass, it means nothing.
Monal S: What is continue? Guys, continue is for loops. Continue cannot be worked in if.
Monal S: Continuous for loops. Don't mess your logic of loops. It is a control flow. Pass is not a control flow.
Monal S: a small PASS.
Monal S: Done. Okay?
Monal S: Yes. Just no logic, nothing. Python will read it, it will not break… let it break the structure, okay? Done. Great.
Monal S: So, guys, this is how we introduce things, okay? In the single day, if I try to put everything, then everyone will be like, what is going on? Okay, so what I will do now, this is class, device, and TV. So, to shorten the code, I will move to the next part that is called as multi-level.
Monal S: You guys can later fill the code, multi-level, as we will not be able to complete the class.
Monal S: So I'm going to create… Multi-level? What is multi-level?
Monal S: See the structure of multi-level?
Monal S: A to B, B to C. Yes?
Monal S: We have a device, And for now, let me… Yes.
Monal S: pass, okay? You can write other functions. Then we have a TV. TV is inheriting the device. TV… Poss?
Monal S: And then there is something called as, let's say, a smart bulk.
Monal S: a smart bulb. It is inheriting from TV.
Monal S: And then… bus.
Monal S: So, see, smart bulbs generating from TV, TV is generating from device, and device is a parent. It is creating a structure like this, so this structure itself is called as…
Monal S: Multi-level.
Monal S: Okay? The structure itself is called as multi-level.
Monal S: Okay, you can write functions. If you want to check these functions, you can just write DFA.
Monal S: And I can do a similar kind of thing, just with different statement.
Monal S: print… ABC.
Monal S: This one has a… TV has A2, Smart Bulbs has A3.
Monal S: So, if I create an object of a smart bulb, I will say S… to be…
Monal S: And multi-level short, ML. ML is multi-level.
Monal S: So we will know what we are doing, okay? Let's try to access all smartball.a3, its own method, able to access.
Monal S: So let's print it.
Monal S: Print is better. It is already printing, right? Yeah.
Monal S: Then.82 easily be able to access, it is even able to access A2.
Monal S: Is it able to access A? It is able to access it.
Monal S: Is this part clear, everyone?
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Guys, I ran the code.
Monal S: Please run your code later, okay? See this.
Monal S: SBML is an object. Guys, at this stage, we should not be asking, is it an object or a variable? Variable holds address. This is an object that's stored in the memory, and a variable holds that reference, okay?
Monal S: We should not compare object with a variable. Object cannot be stored without a variable. Okay, both are different things. Next, the next topic is…
Monal S: Multiple inheritance.
Monal S: multiple inheritance, okay? So, here I'm going to talk about, different things, okay? Let's suppose I have
Monal S: a class called as Camera.
Monal S: Okay? Camera has its own functionalities.
Monal S: Camera can click photo.
Monal S: Self… Print, photo.
Monal S: Okay? Similarly, I'm just going to copy the structure. Camera is one of the functionality, then I will say phone.
Monal S: Phone is one of the functionality. Phone application I'm talking about. Phone application can do the call, and here I will write call, okay? Now, these are different applications, these are different properties, and I want to use it in another class.
Monal S: So here, what I will do… Class called as a smartphone.
Monal S: Here, I will inherit both. I want to inherit camera first.
Monal S: And I want to inherit phone second.
Monal S: Okay, inherit camera first, inherit phone, and I will pass. This class does not have anything of its own. If I run it, create a smartphone, I will just say SP, and this is multiple inheritance.
Monal S: not ML, multi-level, it is multiple. So, smartphone SMP, let's create it, and… SMP can call, let's see.
Monal S: SMP is able to call.
Monal S: The smartphone is able to call, the smartphone is able to click photo. Let's see whether the smartphone is able to click photo.
Monal S: A smartphone is able to click photo as well.
Monal S: Thank you, Leanne.
Monal S: So, see this, how I'm doing. When TV requires a device, and a smartphone requires a TV, then we are doing something like this, okay? Different, different levels. When we require two of the attributes in a single go, then we use something like this.
Monal S: Okay? So, in both the cases, both of them can be achieved, you can see.
Monal S: If you want to have access to both camera and phone, you can also use multi-level, but this is just a different way to inheriting, because people, just like we have learned, right? If I create a variable, a function called as add, can I pass two values? Yes. Can I pass one value? Then you have to use default. If I want to pass multiples, then we learned
Monal S: Different things, yes? We were learning multiple things.
Monal S: So, this is the same kind of a concept where we are using inheritance for multiple things, multiple ways to do the inheritance. Simple, multi-level, multiple. In interview, they will ask you the difference between multi-level and multiple. Then you will tell that
Monal S: In multi-level, it follows a sequence one by one. In multi-level, we can, inherit multiples into… in a single go. Okay? This is what multi-level inheritance is.
Monal S: One thing that we need to keep in mind, that there is one strong analogy that we need to follow. It is not a mandatory, but it is something that we should follow for system design things, okay? So when we talk about inheritance.
Monal S: When we talk about inheritance, guys, just give me a second.
Monal S: It's getting one call.
Monal S: When we talk about inheritance, inheritance should follow a… is a rule.
Monal S: is a rule, okay?
Monal S: If you can follow, it's fine. If you don't follow, it's also fine. But from Fisher Design point of view, if someone asks you this question, you should know it, okay? It means it should have is a relation.
Monal S: it should have is our relationship. Example, if…
Monal S: I'm talking about a dogger class.
Monal S: And it is trying to inherit from animal.
Monal S: Are we able to find out that relationship? Dog is a animal?
Monal S: Dog is a animal.
Monal S: So, this relationship we are able to find. When we have this relationship, then it is okay to do the inheritance. It means we want to bring the property of animal into the dog.
Monal S: Okay? We want to have… this is how we should relate it, when we should use inheritance. So if you are able to have this relationship, or some attributes that is present there, we want to bring it, then do it. Make a coding like this. This is from the system design point of view. And whenever you see something like this.
Monal S: you have a class called as angel.
Monal S: Okay? You have a class called as car, and you have an engine.
Monal S: Are we able to have a relationship? Car is an engine. Car is not an engine. Car…
Monal S: has an engine. So whenever you feel like we have a one bigger class.
Monal S: which should have multiple properties. It should have, okay? It means these are different two entities.
Monal S: So, in this particular case, let's suppose I'm just going to give you an example, okay?
Monal S: Plus.
Monal S: Okay? A class called as animal.
Monal S: not sure what all the animals have in common, so just… I'm just going to write.
Monal S: Animal can speak.
Monal S: Okay, and then we will write…
Monal S: And then I'm just doing pass. Everyone knows now what is pass. Now, if I create dog.
Monal S: Okay? And then I will say… dog attributes, DEF, let's say.
Monal S: bark. I know this is kind of contradicting speak and bark, but now this dog has an ability of… this dog has an ability of speak as well.
Monal S: Yes? So, dog is an animal, animal is having its common entities. Now, if I talk about car and engine.
Monal S: If I talk about car and engine, DEF car.
Monal S: Car will have… car will have wheels.
Monal S: Car will have drive.
Monal S: Car should have… Engine.
Monal S: Right? So, if there is some other… let me just write it as a class.
Monal S: There's a class called car. If I create another class called engine, then should this car inherit engine properties or use engine properties?
Monal S: this car should use engine properties. So what we will do, in that case, in that particular case, we will, in the init, in the init.
Monal S: We will initialize the engine, we are not inheriting it. We will initialize the engine to E, and then use the properties of engine.
Monal S: And then use the properties of engine. So, this is not a mandatory, I'm just giving you a system design point of view, that
Monal S: From the very start, if you have a control, follow is a rule, or follow has a rule. If you have a control.
Monal S: If you are joining some organization which has already created all these levels of inheritance, then don't even go to is a rule, has a rule. Forget about it. But this is a rule, if you can think about in a direction that I want to follow some property, which I can reuse.
Monal S: the animal property I can use in other animals.
Monal S: But engine property, I cannot use it always, yes? In car, I will be using it. So, let's create it. So, as a rule, and is a rule, okay? Is this clear? So, smartphone has camera and phone, okay? Smart… this is totally about design.
Monal S: design concept.
Monal S: For you, it is optional.
Monal S: We should also learn how to develop better softwares, and this is one of them.
Monal S: Is this part clear?
Monal S: Just a design concept, guys. Just a design concept.
Monal S: Yes, Mohan, correct.
Monal S: Guys, in Java, we don't support multiple. Java does not support this. Python supports all.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Sumit.
Monal S: All attributes of it.
Monal S: We almost… we have seen, right?
Monal S: See, private or not, so private is only within class, Sumit. Everyone, if I talk about scope from the developer point of view, if I talk about the scope, can we inherit, if other class inheriting something, can we inherit… where is my code?
Monal S: They're not.
Monal S: Okay, I think it is here, in our notebook.
Monal S: Will we be able to inherit the private variables of a class?
Monal S: Sande will explain.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: No.
Monal S: It is saying that only inside class we are supposed to use, but as we know that this is all kind of a concept which developer needs to follow, we can find a way to do that, but when we inherit it, we will not be able to access it directly, okay?
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Guys, I'm talking about it. There are a lot of concepts, guys. Oops, is a lot of concept. But is everyone getting a hold of object-oriented programming? This is not a… this is not about logic. This is a way we do programming.
Monal S: Is everyone clear? This is a way we do programming. We structure things, it's all about that. And guys, this thing is something which you need to,
Monal S: Practice a lot, okay? Because this is how industry follows. Thank you very much, Sumit. Thank you. So guys, if I show you one of the codes here, I personally like computer vision a lot, so I will show you…
Monal S: Ultralytics, okay? Oops, getting interested. Great.
Monal S: Is everyone able to see this? Don't say to share this website. This website you guys can check anytime. This is not a website which we are learning.
Monal S: Thank you very much, Karthik. Okay, so here we are able to see that there is some repository.
Monal S: And then there are a lot of files. If I click on any of these files, see this, how big our repository is.
Monal S: If we, at the start, don't learn how to do coding, how to do a structured coding, our code will never grow this big. We will not be able to grow it, okay? So, let me talk and open any of this file.
Monal S: Are we able to see class, and in any tense, are we able to read it now?
Monal S: Are we able to read it now?
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: There is some class called as pause predictor, and it is inheriting properties of detection.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: The detection prediction is a post-predictor, it is a type of it. So, kind of, they are following that. Are we able to understand this?
Monal S: How many of you are able to understand this?
Monal S: It's a different module seal.
Monal S: Obviously, it is a different model.
Monal S: Yes? How many of you are able to understand this? Yes. Everyone here is able to understand it.
Monal S: Little confusing? Guys.
Monal S: This is what I'm talking about from the very start of this class. A class inheriting something, don't worry about the code. Forget it.
Monal S: Now, there is another method, it has self and some variables. Don't worry about all the code, this is what I'm talking about. Did I talk about this rewave? Not. I will talk about it later, okay? In this class itself.
Monal S: Okay? So, one by one, we are learning things, how to create. Logic building is something that we are learning in the assignments. Yes, this is something which we will learn here. So, guys, logic building, assignments, practice later, but concepts, coding, we will learn in the class.
Monal S: Encapsulation is also good for you.
Monal S: Okay. So, are we clear? First half, we did this. Second half, we will learn the next two, which will not take this much time. I know I have to write a lot of code still, but you will learn a lot of things. Are you enjoying the class, guys?
Monal S: Are you learning more about Python? Guys, you should also learn what Python is, what works, what does not work. That's great.
Monal S: Okay, awesome, awesome.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Tayer no.
Monal S: Oh, DSA. Sayed, you have to practice, you have to check my answer. Okay, alright guys, so let's start a timer.
Monal S: Chandan will talk about it, okay?
Monal S: And then?
Monal S: That is a programming logic that you need to understand, but later.
Monal S: Parts, as I told you. Read this part.
Monal S: I will explain again at the end, okay?
Monal S: Guys, I will explain everything, can we go on break?
Monal S: Can we go on break?
Monal S: Sure.
Monal S: 20 minutes break I've started, and I'm also going, and I will see you guys after 20 minutes. Let's not waste more time. See you guys, bye-bye.
Monal S: Hey, everyone!
Monal S: Are we guys back?
Monal S: Are you here?
Monal S: Awesome, awesome. Yes?
Monal S: Feeling energetic?
Monal S: Fully? Great. Awesome.
Monal S: So, now, not well today.
Monal S: Raj will take care.
Monal S: It's great that you attended, but take rest as well, take care of yourself.
Monal S: I don't care.
Monal S: That may not know later, okay?
Monal S: When we will discuss more concepting, then we'll talk about that.
Monal S: Thank you very much, Prince. Thank you.
Monal S: Thank you very much, Rajpir. Yes.
Monal S: Guys, I am audible, yes. I don't know the sign language, so people who are audible to hear, how could I say not audible? Okay.
Monal S: Ugh.
Monal S: All right.
Monal S: Okay, so let's go to the next part of today's class. Guys, there are a lot of things, I know oops concept is large, but once you get familiar with this whole oops thing, it is more like a design thinking, okay? It's more, as I told you, this is a designing concept which we reuse.
Monal S: Alright, chat is disabled. Now let's talk about the next topic that is called as method overriding. We all know what is overriding. I told you that…
Monal S: when I have, in a list, 1, 2, 3. Why I did not take a variable? Why I did not take a simple integer variable? Because…
Monal S: If I try to do A equals to 4, a new memory allocation happens, right? So this is not method overriding. We have seen one example of method overriding in a list, that is, if I want to update this value of 1,
Monal S: A of 0 is equals to 2. What will happen to the new list if my A is equal to 1, 2, 3, and I want to update 2 at the location of 0?
Monal S: How should I do it? This is how I should do it. And if I print A, now A will look like this.
Monal S: 2, comma 2, comma 3.
Monal S: I hope everyone is clear in this concept.
Monal S: I hope everyone is clear in this concept. Guys, chat is enabled. This is what we have already done. This is called as overriding, value overriding. We are overriding some value, right? Now I will talk about in terms of classes.
Monal S: Okay, so check disable. Now see what should happen in terms of class. So, if I have a class called parent, or better write code, because here I'm also writing code.
Monal S: But using my pen? Okay.
Monal S: What is the concept name?
Monal S: important, all the things which we learn in here, in OOPS, is a con… is an interview material, okay? Because they check your design skills.
Monal S: Overriding. Okay? Method overriding.
Monal S: Yes, I was talking about an interview, they checked this, because AI is able to write the code, but if you're not able to think in terms of how you should structure your whole project code, where things should be present, then how can you really be a good, logical developer?
Monal S: Right? Logic can be written by AI, but not… thinking part can also be done, but the superior thinking is still with us.
Monal S: Not with AI. Okay. So, method revitalizing means is same method name. What should I… what should happen when I have two classes with the same name? So, I have a class called A.
Monal S: Okay, I'm just writing basic things. I have a class called A, here I have a function called as speak.
Monal S: A is speaking, okay? A, and also the first thing should be self. A does what?
Monal S: I'm just writing parent speak. This one, I'm making it as a parent, okay? Then, I am writing another class called B, which is inheriting
Monal S: A. Now, what should happen?
Monal S: Both the classes, this one should also have a speak, this one should also
Monal S: B class also have a speak, but the print is different. A class also has a speak, but a print is different.
Monal S: Now, as we all know that B is inheriting the property, it means it is also inheriting the method. So, method speak is also now present with B, but B is saying that this is the new definition.
Monal S: So, when this is called as overriding, you are… you are telling… you are telling that this is the new method, this is the new definition of speak, which I am implementing here in my child class. So, when I run it, when I create an object of
Monal S: When I create an object of B, I'm just going to write OB1, okay? Or OBJ1, object1, better. And then, if I print speak.
Monal S: If I call speak.print, then I will see child speak. So, the A inheritance, whatever the method was, is lost, okay? We are not able to see that.
Monal S: Done. Okay? So, is this part clear? Don't worry, I'm going to teach you next, but only tell me in the chat, are you able to understand that the parent speak was lost, is being overridden, is being overridden by the child class? Is this part clear to everyone?
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Why it happens? Because it is designed in a way, if both of them have a speak, how Python will know which speak you are talking about?
Monal S: You are talking about the speak which you are creating the object for. So, this is the speak. If I create an object of A, which does not inherit anything, it has its own speak, but B is inheriting A, and writing the same method, only one name can exist, right? How can Python say that, let's have both of them?
Monal S: There is a way, and now we will learn about it, okay?
Monal S: Learn this concept very, very, very important. This is a concept of… Okay, let's understand this.
Monal S: When we have a class, when we have a class called A,
Monal S: And it has few things. Let's say a… here we write its connection, and then we do something, right? Here I can do, and then its own thing, yes?
Monal S: This is what our normal class looks like.
Monal S: When we create an object, an instance, when we create an instance, the same thing is object, let's suppose this one is called as OBJ1. This OBJ1 will hold
Monal S: Address… of memory location where this class A is present in the memory. Yes? Everyone knows this?
Monal S: Here, we will have a small block. This block will have all the components of Class A, including everything.
Monal S: variables…
Monal S: methods, whatever, right? This OBJ1 holds the address. This one is creating the, object, right? Initializing the object.
Monal S: So, this OBJ1 is also the same as self1 I told you in the previous class, because self is what? Itself. What is itself? Itself is this address which is pointing to the memory. What is this address? So, OBJ1 and self is also same.
Monal S: So now tell me, everyone, is this part clear? I told you before.
Monal S: I told you before, is this part clear? Self and OBJ is same. OBJ is that object, self is that connection, which is using to connect to everything. Great, awesome.
Monal S: Awesome.
Monal S: Now, now that we know this concept, let's suppose this Class A.
Monal S: Let's suppose this class A is inheriting another class called as B.
Monal S: another class called SP. So let me write… Class B.
Monal S: And Class B has its few in it, just going to make it a little complex. We should not always go with the simpler code, okay?
Monal S: This is init. Here, I have written, let's suppose, Self.name is equals to data.
Monal S: Okay, very simple. Then I have… BEF, let's say… B.
Monal S: Hey, I do have a habit of self. If I don't write self.
Monal S: Coding does not run in this notebook, but you should always do the same. That's how you remember something, okay? And then, we have some method. So, when we are inheriting B, okay, when we are inheriting B, let's also create A. DEFA. A is also here. The same A is also here.
Monal S: So tell me when I inherit B into the A, and call, and call, OBJ1.a.
Monal S: Which class A is going to run? Tell me, everyone, which class A is going to run? This is the full code.
Monal S: which class A is going to run.
Monal S: Class A. Because Class BA is overridden by… this is how we should write it. We should say, Class BA is overwritten by Class A. So this one is going to write…
Monal S: class A.A. Yes? Is everyone able to understand this?
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand this?
Monal S: Now comes the problem statement.
Monal S: Okay, disabling the chat.
Monal S: Now comes… A problem of segment.
Monal S: I am okay with Class A overriding Class BA, but what happens if I want to use… if I want to use
Monal S: Class BA.
Monal S: What should I do in order to run class BA as well?
Monal S: So, OVJ, as I told you, is self.
Monal S: Right? OBJ, I told you, is self. There is a special keyword. There is a special keyword when we inherit some other class. When we inherit some other class, the other class to invoke other class. See? Are we creating the object of be anywhere?
Monal S: Are we creating the object of B anywhere? No, we are not creating. To directly call the object of… to directly call the object of inherited class, we say a word called as super.
Monal S: S-U-P-E-R. So, in code, in this code of A, in this code of… I will show you, in this code of A, if I will call super, Python will first check
Monal S: Do we have inherited class?
Monal S: Python will first check.
Monal S: Do we have… parent class… Do we have parent class? Answer is yes.
Monal S: If answer is yes, what is that class? Class is B.
Monal S: It is B. So when we call this super, it means We are calling the object.
Monal S: We are calling the object. And when this one is creating object.
Monal S: If this one is creating object, can I do this?
Monal S: This one is the object, this one is creating the object, we are not storing it. I told you same in the Python as well, right? When we were doing it like this…
Monal S: Calling a function, let's suppose function add 2,3 I'm passing, which has its own functionality, but I can also add it like this. This function will return me 5, and then 5 plus 3.
Monal S: I am not saving it anywhere, I'm just using the value directly. Similarly, when I'm calling super, Python will check, do we have a parent class? If yes, what is that parent class? Then, it will create something like this.
Monal S: Now I want to use B of A. B of A is its own
Monal S: B of A is its own A method.
Monal S: In this way, we'll be able to call it. So, first, look at the code, then we will talk about the dot, okay? Very simple. So, self is for itself, super is for…
Monal S: Super is for the parent class. Super is always targeting to the parent class, okay?
Monal S: So, this time, we will talk about… where is that? Yeah, we are still in method overriding.
Monal S: Okay, so now that we have this B, now let me call this B in a better way.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Need.
Monal S: Three hands are raised, guys, you will understand, first, say this.
Monal S: Okay? Okay. In this A, see this, what I'm trying to do? In this A, I will do DF in it.
Monal S: DF innate, or I can just check.
Monal S: 6.
Monal S: This is a function called a speak. Speak is doing this. Now, inside the speak, I want to make something like this, yeah.
Monal S: Super? See this? Super is not creating error. Super means? Super means object of A.
Monal S: Super means object of A, I want to call what?
Monal S: I want to call what? A.
Monal S: No, speak, sorry. Speak.
Monal S: So what will happen now? When I create an object of B, object of B is created. When I do B.speak, it will run this function. In this method, what happens? In this method, the first line is, we are calling super. Super means, object A speak.
Monal S: Object A is big means?
Monal S: It will create an object of A, call the speak, we will see print speak.
Monal S: Okay, it will say Prince Speak. After print speak, what we will see, we will see Child Speak.
Monal S: So let me run this code.
Monal S: Are we able to see that?
Monal S: Everyone, I've enabled the chat. Is everyone able to understand this concept? Very simple. Super itself means whatever we have inherited, we are creating the object.
Monal S: Super means… A class. When we do class with bracket, it means the object. Yes or no?
Monal S: Replace it with this.
Monal S: Super itself means whatever you inherited. So when I write super, Python will automatically say what we have inherited, A will be replaced with, A will be replaced with, super will be replaced with.
Monal S: A. A.Speak is, object of a.speak is this?
Monal S: Harsh, is this clear now?
Monal S: Is this clear, Noel?
Monal S: Hi, that's…
Monal S: Hi there, guys, is chat enabled or something? Disabled or something? Okay. Yeah, sorry. Now it is clear. Is this clear now? For some reason, it got muted. Yes?
Monal S: phase… Name is this?
Monal S: I'm all… If we don't write self, Self, guys?
Monal S: One thing about self, self is just for connection. You can write S, you can write S,
Monal S: You can do S here, you can do A here, it's not at all an issue.
Monal S: it should be the first argument in… this S should be shared between all its members. Yes? Everyone should know.
Monal S: Guys, what is the confusion point? Tell me where you are confused.
Monal S: Tell me where you were confused.
Monal S: Tell me where you're confused.
Monal S: Sumit, that will be solved by MRO, I will talk about it, okay?
Monal S: Later. I will talk about it, don't worry.
Monal S: That part is already here.
Monal S: Yes, guys, whoever… guys, I'm just asking, in this code, do you have an issue? If you are talking about complex code, which I have not taught yet, let's not talk about that right now.
Monal S: Anyone is having any issue here, all your queries, like multiple, multiple narratives, that is a different thing.
Monal S: In Coq, I'm not using any initials. There is no limit.
Monal S: No issue.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: So guys, I'm repeating it, sometimes you have to think also in your head that I told you super is nothing but a reference. When I say super keyword, it is the reference of A itself.
Monal S: This whole thing will be replaced by A, so when I do A of this, when I do B of this, what I will get, I will get object. When I do A of this, I will get object of A. Object of A.Speak will run.
Monal S: this…
Monal S: So, even though I'm calling OBJ1.speak, the first priority is, it is overridden, it will not call A. But here, we are specifically targeting to run A object.
Monal S: Is this part clear? Now we want to control… in this way, we can override what override does. Override is overriding the speakOfA, that part is not in our control. But we can call the method A… we can call the method speakOfClass A using super keyword.
Monal S: Okay? Using super keyword. And guys, if you can also do this, you can also write DF in it.
Monal S: NN8, you can write self.
Monal S: So, when you create an object, when you create an object itself, you can call super, it's totally up to you.
Monal S: It's totally up to you.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: The main question is, why not? Guys, whenever you think of something, ask yourself, why not?
Monal S: Python is just Python. It will run whatever you say. So now, if I run this init, when I create this object of B itself, it will run super.speak, it will print parent.
Monal S: So, see this? Run it. Here itself, we will see that.
Monal S: Yes? Now when I do speak, will I see parent speak?
Monal S: When I call speak of OBJ1, will I see parent speak? No. We will not be able to see that.
Monal S: Yes, it is possible, Pradyod. But, as I told you, first focus here, later I will talk about more complex things.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Guys, I told you, someone asked me, can we have anything parent?
Monal S: How many of you think that we cannot have anything parent? Guys, I know you are the starting, beginning as a coder.
Monal S: Why not?
Monal S: Do you have an answer of why not?
Monal S: If you don't have answer of why not, it means you need to run it.
Monal S: I am inside A.
Monal S: What will happen now?
Monal S: Super, let's see!
Monal S: Are we able to… Guys, what is… we are doing?
Monal S: No, self is declared. Self is the connection name, object name. But yeah, it is kind of similar. So, see this. Here we told B, here we told that when you run this, only run super.speak.
Monal S: object.speak.
Monal S: If I want this one to run the init as well, we need to specifically tell
Monal S: super dot underscore underscore init. Then only it will run init.
Monal S: Are we able to understand now? So, whatever we will say, it will do that. That's all.
Monal S: Because it is inheriting the property, we are not creating the actual object, just like we do it, we are creating the indirect object. So, indirect object does not run init automatically, it will go to the speak. If you want to run it directly, then we have to do that.
Monal S: Okay. Okay.
Monal S: So, how many of you want to see an actual example of this? Actual example of this?
Monal S: How many of you want to do that? Okay.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: This may be different, yeah. Okay, let's see.
Monal S: Let me create a design.
Monal S: Even though class will be a little slow, not able to complete everything, how many of you are fine? Do not complain me at later.
Monal S: Little bit, only 10 minutes it will take.
Monal S: Only 10 minutes will take, fine.
Monal S: disabled.
Monal S: So let's design first thing. Coding is the last thing which I personally do, and I'm learning that. I was not doing that in my junior stage. Okay, so let's see, in which cases… in which cases do we need to use a class? In which cases we need to use a class?
Monal S: And also, the init.
Monal S: And also the init.
Monal S: Okay? So… yep.
Monal S: Let's use this.
Monal S: Can I create… simple, everyone understand this, okay? Can I create a class of… motherboard.
Monal S: motherboard, okay?
Monal S: This is a class of motherboard. In the init, in the init, we will have cells, and I will initialize a few things like how much RAM you have.
Monal S: Talking?
Monal S: how much RAM you have, And how much… what is your CPU? Or… yes.
Monal S: CPU speed, we will write CPU speed in gigahertz, okay? For now, we will only put 2. Then, motherboard should also have a functionality
Monal S: motherboard should also have a functionality of start.
Monal S: Okay? Motherboard should also have a functionality of start.
Monal S: And it should also have a functionality of stop, that is, to cut the power. This is our motherboard, right? And here, we will also write a few things like…
Monal S: Here, we will also write few things like.
Monal S: what is current time, okay? Current time, we will also note. I will talk about it, how to add the time, but we are… I'm just going to use something dummy here, okay? Something dummy here. Then, what I'm going to do, I'm going to create a class called as our computer, our actual personal computer.
Monal S: This is going to inherit motherboard, okay? This is going to inherit motherboard, and… In the init.
Monal S: And it's in it, We want to initialize, and it's init, we want to initialize the motherboard.
Monal S: Okay? In the motherboard.
Monal S: And then… I will create a function, Start computer.
Monal S: Okay, I will create start computer. Also, let me write CPU type.
Monal S: What I will do in StartComputer, I will take one of the variables which we initialized, I will take one of the variables we initialized, and check if
Monal S: If the CPU… if the CPU type is, let's say.
Monal S: What is that CPU which we get in Mac? I forgot the name. Yeah, M1 chip.
Monal S: If the CPU type is Apple Provider.
Monal S: Then, we will call, then we will call another function, we will call another function.
Monal S: which I'm going to write here, that is, start… macOS.
Monal S: If… Alive?
Monal S: Start something else.
Monal S: Simple. So, once I write the code, then you will understand it better. So what I'm going to do, I'm going to put everything in my other screen, so I know what is going on. So, give me a second, okay?
Monal S: Okay, now let's create it.
Monal S: Example.
Monal S: Let's create, and let me create it fast.
Monal S: Don't want to waste time. We have a class called Motherboard.
Monal S: Okay? A motherboard is the parent class, so it should have some properties which we require from it, okay? I'm not talking about design components here, I'm just talking about
Monal S: what I need to complete first, okay? So this is self, and I need a few things from the motherboard when we initialize, but for now, let's suppose my motherboard
Monal S: ramp. By default, Need to add motherboard.
Monal S: So… I need RAM.
Monal S: I need CPU speed, which user will provide. I need time.
Monal S: time I will add later.
Monal S: And I need… CPU type.
Monal S: Then I will write self.
Monal S: RAM is equals to RAM.
Monal S: self.
Monal S: CPU speed.
Monal S: is equals to CPU speed. All of these things, user will provide self.cpuType.
Monal S: User will also provide. So, when user will buy this motherboard, they will provide all of this configuration of the motherboard, okay? Then here, motherboard should have some functions, that is to start.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: print.
Monal S: Power flow started. I'm just writing power flow started. Very weird thing, it should have self.
Monal S: Not making it too complex. I cannot create a motherboard logic, okay?
Monal S: And then stop, power flow stopped.
Monal S: Okay? So this motherboard has start and stop functionality that we already have it here. Now done. Now what I'm going to do, I'm going to create a class called computer
Monal S: And then, in computer, I'm going to inherit motherboard.
Monal S: So, now I have configuration. So, in its init, in its init.
Monal S: I will take the same parameters, Because when I…
Monal S: when I'm buying the… I'm not buying just motherboard, I'm buying computer. And in that… in that package itself, I want to buy the motherboard as well. So, I will tell, while buying the computer, that I want to buy this RAM, CPU, and CPU type, because user who is not technical is not going to buy a motherboard. They are going to buy a computer with some minimum configurations, okay?
Monal S: And then, here what I'm going to do, I am going to call the super in it.
Monal S: What super init is going to do?
Monal S: Superinnate is going to initialize all the variables that we have here, which user is passing.
Monal S: which user is passing to this motherboard. So, everything will be re-initialized, and all the variables we will also get here. And once all the variables are initialized here, self.ram is also accessible in computers, self.cpuspeed is also compatible.
Monal S: So now, what I will do, the next method I'm going to create, see this?
Monal S: Check. OS… and set… OS type.
Monal S: Okay? See this? This is how we do coding, even if it feels a little complex to all of you at the start. Later, you guys can figure it out, okay?
Monal S: In the meantime. So, what I want to do, if…
Monal S: are… do we have access of CPU type now? Once I run the superinit, that is the first command of this init, I will be able to initialize all the CPU type, so whatever I will pass. So, in CPU type, if I pass CPU type.lower.
Monal S: is equals to… Mac.
Monal S: I just… I will just write Macchip, okay? This is self.cpuType. I will have access to it. Right now, I have not written it, but while I'm inheriting it, I have access to self.cpu, CPU type.
Monal S: Then I will write.
Monal S: Just wait, guys, don't worry, I will explain everything.
Monal S: Say this. I am calling this particular function, and this function will return me the OS. So right now, I need to write that functionality. So, I will do the return of…
Monal S: Mac.
Monal S: Else?
Monal S: I will return.
Monal S: Probably.
Monal S: Okay? So this particular function is taking… this has self, it has a connection, so it also has access to self or CPU type. If user write MAC chip, I will return Mac. Else, I will write other.
Monal S: So this function I'm calling from init itself, so in init, I'm calling checkOS and set OS type. This will return any of this to value, which I will set in OS, right? Now, what I will do, finally, I will call… this one is done. Now, user can call…
Monal S: tag my… OS. Very simple. Very simple. I'm just doing random, complex things.
Monal S: User has… User has…
Monal S: back.
Monal S: voice.
Monal S: DF properties.
Monal S: That's it. Okay. For now, I'm doing this. Everyone see this. Very, very simple.
Monal S: I have a motherboard, which has a functionality of start and stop, that I have not implemented in computer. My computer should give me high-level things, such like computer. I'm able to see screen, I'm able to do things. So this computer is letting me, is letting me access to check my OS.
Monal S: And just like variable, I told you, right? Just like variable at the start, that is having here in calculation, we can also include
Monal S: We can also include things here.
Monal S: I want this to be a private method. That is, only a method of this class can use it.
Monal S: Yes? Is it true? Yes?
Monal S: Only inside class, I'm able to use this method, but I can use this in public, so I will call this as
Monal S: Public method?
Monal S: And I will call this as… private.
Monal S: Method. Okay, same concept of variable, but just method. Done. So…
Monal S: I don't have to worry about whether I have a start or a stop, that is a functionality of motherboard. Motherboard would have a start and a stop. Motherboard is having all the details, which I will, as a customer, if when I go to buy the computer, I will say that I need 12GB of RAM,
Monal S: let me pass string. I need 12GB of RAM,
Monal S: I made a system with at least 4.2 GHz of speed, okay?
Monal S: and then my CPU type, okay? My CPU type, can I write here something like this?
Monal S: Enter…
Monal S: Okay, for now, simple. Class is extending. Max chip.
Monal S: So once this will go here, it will go to the init of the computer. The first command is, we are passing these values, so RAM, CPU speed, and CPU type will go to motherboard, it will catch here and initialize all these values.
Monal S: Now, because of inheritance, we have access to all these variables in the computer also.
Monal S: So, what we are doing in the init, we are calling check the OS and set OS type, so we can do later things. So, in init, what we are doing, we're initializing the parent. Also, we are checking few things in the init itself.
Monal S: So that we are… I don't want to call this, I want to automatically get this and get me the OS. So in this function, I am passing self. Self means it has access to all the variables of both the classes. Here, I'm checking if user pass Mac chip, return Mac as return other.
Monal S: So it will run it, and when I create the object, it will do this as well as this. So I have access to all the variables, plus I set the new value of OS.
Monal S: So, this is done. So, let me write, this is CMP1.
Monal S: Computer one.
Monal S: Now this computer one, if I try to access… if I try to call this method.
Monal S: It is not permitted.
Monal S: Okay? And we cannot create a method just like a variable, so now this is providing a better security. But as a user perspective, I am only allowing user… to check it…
Monal S: User never written macOS.
Monal S: User never written macOS, user never know that they have this information, they just know that this is their CPU, this is what they're getting. But also.
Monal S: Does user has access to start the system?
Monal S: Yes. Does user have access to stop the system?
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: So, user has a complete OS, user can get something, user can start something, user can stop something.
Monal S: So, this part is done. This is what I wanted to show you. Is everyone able to understand?
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand?
Monal S: So, guys, you guys can clear, you guys can create your own way. It's not the only way, but this is how we should think it.
Monal S: This is how we should think it. We are to use, where we are able to utilize few things. I know, guys, I'm not saying that you should understand 100% of this, but is everyone, doubt clear? Why in it
Monal S: Everyone, are we clear why in it? Because we want to.
Monal S: Super init is… without super init, will I be able to access self.cpuType?
Monal S: without super innate, will I be able to access self.cpuType?
Monal S: No, without innate, these variables will never initialize, so I am passing these variables here.
Monal S: Are we able to understand the value of private method now? If the method itself is private, variable I'm able to access?
Monal S: variable I'm able to access, but I make… if I make a variable… method itself as a private, then…
Monal S: I will not be able to use it.
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: If you want to check… see this? The CMP1 also has access to parent variables, so if I write RAM,
Monal S: Will I be able to access RAM? Guys, tell me yes or no.
Monal S: If I run this code, what will happen?
Monal S: Because of inheritance, Is this amazing? Is this way of coding amazing?
Monal S: I personally feel so, guys.
Monal S: I personally feel that using object-oriented programming gives you a lot of power. You have everything in your control. In normal function and definition, you have to do this simple thing, you have to write a lot of global variables, and everything will be out of place.
Monal S: How many of you agree on this?
Monal S: Oops is complex if you don't know what you are doing with coding, guys.
Monal S: Oops is complex if you don't know what you're doing with coding. If you… this is what I want you to learn. These assignments are there to open your mind, okay? Once you think… that's why I'm from the day one, I'm asking you to do dry run. If coding does not run in your mind, coding will not run in your system.
Monal S: Are we clear? So guys, the same concept applies. If I create a function without an underscore, it is public. If I create with double underscore, it is a private. Private, I told you at the start, what is the meaning of private? Only inside class.
Monal S: variables I can access, but if the method itself is private, I will not be able to access the method outside it.
Monal S: I have to use that weird method, okay? I have to use that weird way.
Monal S: Why will check my OS lead to an error? CheckOS.
Monal S: Why will it lead to error?
Monal S: Nave, why will this, calling this in the init will lead to error?
Monal S: I am using its own method inside its own class.
Monal S: This is computer, this is computer method. I'm using computer method inside the computer class.
Monal S: Second method, is it a definition?
Monal S: Or using it.
Monal S: Guys, People who are not able to understand, guys, can you please do try run?
Monal S: Okay, tell me, everyone who is confused with super. Guys, what is super? Okay, first I will ask you.
Monal S: Who is that? Tanme, tell me what is super.
Monal S: Tell me what is super?
Monal S: others, guys.
Monal S: What is super tell me?
Monal S: Super is what? Super is used for inheritance?
Monal S: Super is what in our context?
Monal S: I told you super means whatever class we inherited.
Monal S: So… Super will be replaced by… Motherboard.
Monal S: it will look like motherboard. Then.
Monal S: The same thing will be here.
Monal S: If I comment it, this super will internally look like this.
Monal S: Because motherboard is the parent, super will be replaced by motherboard.
Monal S: Is this part clear to everyone?
Monal S: Super is not used for inheritance. Once we inherit, to call the parent directly, we use super.
Monal S: Super is not used for inheritance, guys. We were using… we were doing inheritance without the super as well. Here, do we have super?
Monal S: How are we able to inherit it? No. Super is not for inheritance, super is… once we inherit, then to call the parent directly is super.
Monal S: Are we clear now, everyone?
Monal S: Is everyone clear now?
Monal S: SciFly, I will talk about it. Just wait, okay?
Monal S: If it does not have any parent, how super will work?
Monal S: It will be just like… What is this super? It does not know that.
Monal S: Ben?
Monal S: If you, instead of calling super, if you call motherboard, to this.
Monal S: It is saying motherboard missing 3 arguments. Because super is a special keyword, it uses this motherboard, but here, what we are trying to do, when we co… if you… guys.
Monal S: See this.
Monal S: Traditional way. Oh, what happened?
Monal S: Everyone? See this?
Monal S: Focus here.
Monal S: It is working.
Monal S: Satish?
Monal S: Oh, because?
Monal S: Batesh will talk about it.
Monal S: Guys?
Monal S: I have a class A, I have class B, which inherits… this is class B.
Monal S: Traditionally, in normal way, to call this object if it has in it.
Monal S: If both of them has in it, say this.
Monal S: If both of them has in it, this is class B,
Monal S: to create an object of A, And pass, let's suppose, variable.
Monal S: And it has… self, comma A, B. This one has self, comma A, comma, B.
Monal S: Okay, this is my two classes.
Monal S: If I want to create an object of A,
Monal S: Here, I know that init requires two more arguments, I need to pass it.
Monal S: Yes, so I require class name and two arguments using normal method.
Monal S: But when B inherits A, But when B inherits A,
Monal S: B also required two arguments, because I have A comma B, so I need to pass it.
Monal S: But, if inside B, I am calling… I want to call A,
Monal S: I want to call A. A is the class which we inherit. How we are going to pass it?
Monal S: If I write a underscore in it, we know that we are supposed to pass values here.
Monal S: We are supposed to pass value here, so we cannot call init like this. So what we have to do, instead of that.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: This is not a traditional way we should be doing it. So, see this? Computer object has no attribute, CPU type, where is that? Computer object, where is computer?
Monal S: has no object CPU time, because in self, we are passing it. So, we are not supposed to create an object like this, this is just for your understanding that super is referring to motherboard.
Monal S: But creating an object like this, like we create for computer, is not, recommended here inside. It will create an error, okay? So this is just for your reference to understand that this is how we are calling, but we should be calling like super. Okay?
Monal S: Clear, everyone.
Monal S: So this is not a good way to call something.
Monal S: This does not look natural. Natural is super.
Monal S: Satish.
Monal S: Guys, really?
Monal S: I told you till inheritance, now you're asking why.
Monal S: Satish is trying to run, because, guys.
Monal S: Satis is trying to run this.
Monal S: Why will it not work?
Monal S: My VS code is automatically giving me a low. Tell me why this line is not working.
Monal S: No, it's not about private. Why it is not working?
Monal S: Correct?
Monal S: Viratar is correct.
Monal S: Rubina is correct.
Monal S: Are bit incorrect.
Monal S: Satish is correct.
Monal S: Rajvir is correct.
Monal S: This is a function Of which class?
Monal S: Self… Let's go to the previous class.
Monal S: Previous class was… Both?
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: While there are a lot of…
Monal S: Where is that? Yes.
Monal S: This is ClassRobot.
Monal S: Why each of them is having self…
Monal S: Why each of them is having self?
Monal S: Each of them is having sell because
Monal S: Withdraw is not known by our bank. It will only know if I want to call withdraw from within the class. I have to use self.
Monal S: Self is that connection which we need to always mention, so here we also mentioned self.balance. If I remove self.
Monal S: Python will not know… this… our bank account will not know that it does have a balance. It will try to look at it as a local variable.
Monal S: Are we clear, Satish?
Monal S: Why we need… why we are doing certain way, others…
Monal S: Why do I need to write self.tis function and not just normal function?
Monal S: This will not work.
Monal S: Is everyone clear why the second line is not working?
Monal S: Because whenever we are calling a function also from within, we need to write
Monal S: Function belongs to super, or function belongs to us.
Monal S: This function belongs to us. I could have written super.
Monal S: Are we clear? I could have written super. Super thought this function, but it belongs to us. That's why I need to write set.
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: So, I'm calling a function. This function is supposed to return me something, and I want to save in my own variable. This is self.os. This is simple, like, if I want to call an add function.
Monal S: my own add function, I want to call whatever the value is, I want to save back to A. But now this A I want to… I want the A to be a self kind of a way, so it should… all the variables should be accessible across.
Monal S: So this is what it means. So, if self is also there, this is what it looks like. Is the confusion clear?
Monal S: Is the confusion clear now, everyone?
Monal S: Okay? I know things are complex, but you will learn it.
Monal S: I'm commenting a lot of things just for your reference. Okay, can we move to the next part?
Monal S: Motu, I will talk about it, okay?
Monal S: Bottom will talk about it, okay?
Monal S: You belong.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Done. Next part.
Monal S: Self is a variable. Word, variable of a class.
Monal S: Okay, let me create one class, okay?
Monal S: So this time, I will say class of A,
Monal S: And I have few things like add…
Monal S: 12, 1… Not that. Maybe I will do this.
Monal S: Just wait, okay?
Monal S: Let's see this.
Monal S: This is what you all have been asking.
Monal S: I will write self… Then here I will write… plus K.
Monal S: And similarly, I will do.
Monal S: four different classes. This one is B.
Monal S: which is trying to inherit A, okay, which is trying to inherit A.
Monal S: And it also has some function called as pay. Just writing few dummy things.
Monal S: This is Class B.
Monal S: It prints class B when you initialize this constructor. It has function method called SB, it prints B. Just going to create a lot of different classes.
Monal S: It prints class C. Then we have a function called as classC.
Monal S: It prints C.
Monal S: And this is D. It prints class D.
Monal S: And then there is a function method called ST, then this is T. Let's suppose class B, I'm just doing random things.
Monal S: Then I want to show you something else, okay? Class B inherits A, so it means it has both function A and B, and in it, I can call it whenever I want, okay? Then there is Class C.
Monal S: Class C inherits A.
Monal S: So Class B also inherits A, Class C also inherits A, so this is how the diagram looks like.
Monal S: This is Class A.
Monal S: Class B inherits A, Class C inherits A. Next, Class D inherits both B, comma, C.
Monal S: Okay? It inherits both B, C.
Monal S: So, D…
Monal S: which inherits both B, C. So, how many functions, how many methods it has access to? It has access to D, it has access to B, C, A, and all the init, we can also call it. Okay? This is what we created.
Monal S: Now, let's see what happens.
Monal S: When I create an object of class D,
Monal S: Let's store into small d. D-O-V-J.
Monal S: D underscore OBJ.
Monal S: So, it has, initialized class D, right? Now, let me write here in the init, super.
Monal S: Because now I have B comma C. Let's see what super it is going to call.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Let's see what N8 it is going to call.
Monal S: So, it called B.
Monal S: Yes, it called D, and then we saw D, right? So when we see it is only calling the first super is the B itself. How we are going to decide how we can see that
Monal S: this B on a hierarchical level, because from here, we are able to see it connected too. How it is deciding that B, is it super? There is a concept called as MRO.
Monal S: Okay, it is implemented in Python, and let me tell you… yes.
Monal S: This MRO is called as…
Monal S: Method, we are not going to learn in depth, we are just introducing it, okay? Method… Resolution, order.
Monal S: MRO, okay? This is used… this is used to find the next method in the inheritance chain.
Monal S: Used to find… Next method… In the inheritance chain.
Monal S: Python uses this internally, okay?
Monal S: Python uses is internally.
Monal S: So, when we call… when we call some object, we are not directly going to the parent. We… because here, in this case, we have B and C, both of them as parent. So, Python usually does what? Python creates a chain. We will see that chain. Maybe Python created a chain like this. So, when we call D, the super is B.
Monal S: But in our diagram, we have a diagram like this.
Monal S: Which is weird. How Python is going to decide between B and C? No, this is not how it will work like. So Python will internally use MRO, that is, method resolution order, which is going to create an order that who is going to be the parent of B, then parent of B is going to be C, parent of C is going to be A. We will see this now.
Monal S: So, we have created this D. Now, if you want to see that, we need to create… if you want to see the chain, what is their sequence, we need to call the last object, last class, which we need to check, and their parents and parents. So, we will call D underscore underscore MRO.
Monal S: This is, again, a special method of every class. See this?
Monal S: Class D, connected to Class B, connected to Class C, then connected to Class A.
Monal S: So what is the chain we are able to see?
Monal S: D to B… 2C to A.
Monal S: And from our diagram, what we saw? From our diagram, D to B to C to A. See this? This is two in parallel, so this is now how it will work, like…
Monal S: So leave with a C.
Monal S: 1, D to B, then… what is the next one? B to C.
Monal S: 2… This is 3, C28. So when we call B.Super, when we call super inside the B,
Monal S: When we call super inside the B, then we will see the name of class C. Let's see that.
Monal S: So here, I'm going to write… super.init.
Monal S: When I call D, D is calling… D is calling B. We are able to see B.
Monal S: And then, B is calling what?
Monal S: Where is B?
Monal S: B is calling B superintend.
Monal S: This is B super in it, it is calling, again, Oh.
Monal S: That's dope.
Monal S: It is calling the parent… okay, one parent at a time.
Monal S: Best way. Not this.
Monal S: Just let me check the chain, guys.
Monal S: put it in it.
Monal S: Then, this init will be calling its own super, So… We are getting…
Monal S: Just wait, okay? Oh, got it, got it. It is current dice, okay? See this.
Monal S: When we are trying to call D, DINIT will run automatically, then DINIT is calling its own init. What is the init of D? B.
Monal S: So, it will go to the B, B in it will call, B in it will call what?
Monal S: B in it will be this function itself, so B will be printed, then class D will be printed, specifically we are able to see that?
Monal S: Where is that?
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: See, I will show you. Because… The flow is weird.
Monal S: This is how MRO works.
Monal S: The best way to debug any code is… Do the driving.
Monal S: It is.
Monal S: This is the output that we got. Let's see whether we understand this output or not.
Monal S: And we also have this code.
Monal S: Okay, let's do one by one, Abby, okay?
Monal S: So, first, we are calling B.
Monal S: First, we are calling D.
Monal S: D init run first. We are running D init.
Monal S: And D in it is calling, DNIT is calling Superinit.
Monal S: Super init.
Monal S: What is the super of D? We know it is B. So, what we will do, we will go to B.
Monal S: B. When we go to the B, we are calling the init of B. In the init of B, what we are calling
Monal S: In the init of B, what we are calling super init.
Monal S: This is B.init.
Monal S: In B.init, we are calling superinit. What is it superunit?
Monal S: What is the super init of P?
Monal S: seat.
Monal S: So we will go to the C.
Monal S: So, we are calling CINIT. C. init.
Monal S: Now, C.init, what we are doing? We don't have any other super. So, we will do what? It will print…
Monal S: C.
Monal S: This part is done, this part is done, C.init is done.
Monal S: Okay? What is the next? Now we will go back reverse. C.unit is printed.
Monal S: What is the next? B dot init?
Monal S: This one was linked to this, so we will print B.
Monal S: And then, once this is also done, what is D.Unit? This part is totally completed now. This part is totally completed. Now we will see class D. CBD. C, B, D.
Monal S: Dry run, guys. Dry run is always the key. Is everyone able to understand the MRO now?
Monal S: Is everyone able to understand the MRO now?
Monal S: Hamaro decides which one you should do.
Monal S: Guys, if you do this, you will be able to understand. Write the sequence. Guys, in the dry run, I will suggest you to try… run the sequence first. This one is calling 1.
Monal S: what is the one? This is 1. This one is calling 2. Then, it will start printing from the previous.
Monal S: Gitanjali, that is being resolved by MRO. MRO is a special method which solves this. To understand MRO, we need to check the logic behind the Python itself. That is not our focus. See this?
Monal S: MRO, we need to check.
Monal S: Okay? So that is the main logic of the Python itself. So, let's not go to how MRO is deciding it, okay? But this is what MRO has decided. Now, the code will work like this.
Monal S: Guys, B super is not C, but in this chain of BBC, this is how it'll work like.
Monal S: Are you clear?
Monal S: Are we clear? DBC, if we check about D, D is connected to BC, because now we have two… yes, it's a diamond problem. So when we have parallel, Python needs to do something.
Monal S: When we have things in parallel, Python needs to create a chain.
Monal S: If Python will create a chain to B but not to C, C is already lost.
Monal S: So Python needs to do something, Python will change something here, okay? So this is MRO, this is not asked in the interview, but this is for your own understanding that when we have a problem statement like this diamond.
Monal S: Okay? Python will decide a chain, because this is not really a chain.
Monal S: When we have 3 different paths, guys, when we have 3 different paths, B, C, D,
Monal S: And then all of them are inheriting E.
Monal S: Python cannot go A to B to E. What will happen to C to E? Python needs to create a way. It needs to create a sequence in which it is going to follow the hierarchy, and using MRO, it follows the hierarchy.
Monal S: So, are we able to see that why this one Where is that?
Monal S: Guys, is this the one blogged in Java?
Monal S: Is this the one blocked in Java?
Monal S: Java, guys. So, guys, this is the reason this is kind of blocked in Java.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: not…
Monal S: not available in Java.
Monal S: That's why we use multi-level.
Monal S: Okay? Only because of this weird thing that how Python is going to resolve it. Java and others does not implement. Java implements B2A, C2A, things like that. Yes, this creates ambiguity.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Is everyone cleared?
Monal S: Sojay?
Monal S: Isn't B and C inheriting A? B and C inheriting A, that is correct. But what will happen to D, that is… what will happen to D, that is… Sujaya, will you be able to solve D and BC?
Monal S: Jujay, do you have an answer of…
Monal S: When we do D, B, or C, what is the sequence?
Monal S: If we can't answer it, it means Python is internally doing something to make sure that it is a sequence.
Monal S: To follow that sequence, it's break few things as well, so make sure that you are not using something like this.
Monal S: If you create an object of C, then you will get A. If you create an object of B, then you will get A. But when you do object of D, which is having B, C, which is having dependent on another one, that B and C creates an issue, that's why you get diamond problem, and to see that, you need to use D.MRO.
Monal S: Sri Kunj, your message is physical.
Monal S: Okay? So, MRO, MRO is not for our developer benefit. I'm just showing you the internal… Guys, if I just run d.super.super and don't show you that, how many of you will be able to understand the behavior?
Monal S: We will never be able to understand the behavior. This behavior is because of MRO. MRO is that technique that does it.
Monal S: MRO is that technique that creates a chain.
Monal S: So, we are not supposed to use MRO or something. MRO is that technique which I'm showing you internally that does it. That's all. That's the use of MR. MRO is not used for ours. MRO is used for Python.
Monal S: Okay? So guys, please do the dry run in your free time, because I did it in front of you, okay? So do it later, okay? Start solving from the bottom.
Monal S: Done?
Monal S: Guys, every permutation combination, do it. For people who are telling me to repeat it, guys, do you want me to not teach anything today?
Monal S: Anything new?
Monal S: Do you want me to do… write more coding of class A, B, C, which you guys can do it at home?
Monal S: How many… Sramit, why your chat will not be visible?
Monal S: See, guys, this is the part which I talk about.
Monal S: 70% of you have the same query, and 70% of you want me to try the coding again.
Monal S: I have never personally did MRO, but I'm able to see MRO, I'm able to do it because I am trying from my side.
Monal S: Was I able to directly conclude the MRI logic? No. I did dry run my own. You guys have to do a dry run of your own.
Monal S: That visible.
Monal S: I'm not getting anything after inheritance. We are still in inheritance.
Monal S: Don't worry. We'll recall, then you guys can revise it later.
Monal S: Okay? Next.
Monal S: So, this is about inheritance. Don't worry about the MRO, I was just showing you in complex things how inheritance will work. The class is in-depth, but you guys can choose at the start to just go… don't even look at this, because you guys asked me, I told you that.
Monal S: So this is, again, an example, let me mark it as a hard. So when you're revising it, if you don't understand at, today, don't worry about this.
Monal S: Understand all the things which I did before. Very, very simple things. Camera, phone, see, that's what I'm saying. People told me, sir, we don't talk about real-world example, real coding. When I do this, you guys understand. When I do this, you guys don't understand.
Monal S: So, by doing it, I'm creating more confusion for people who don't understand.
Monal S: Okay? So let's not waste any more time. We have completed this, the other two. Inheritance is just inheriting the property, for now.
Monal S: People who understand that, please stay in this spot.
Monal S: Devices power on, TVs show. If you understand this inheritance, don't worry about it, okay? You will understand all with more practice. You should also know what is method overriding. Same speak in two different classes.
Monal S: In class, where we are inheriting is going to override, so parent will be lost. If you want to use it, you use super. Super is nothing but the name of the parent class, okay? That is inheritance.
Monal S: So, next, let me talk about… Distribute, okay?
Monal S: And guys, for Java people, method. Overloading is not, possible endowment.
Monal S: I invite them.
Monal S: So I'm a favorite.
Monal S: For Python people, this is for their personal programming language, don't worry about it, okay? It can be achieved, but it is a weird method. It is not really true overloading.
Monal S: Let's go to the next part.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Composition we have completed is, is, has, And, alright.
Monal S: What part is left?
Monal S: The next topic is… abstraction.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Okay. Next topic is abstraction. Guys.
Monal S: if you are not able to learn before, understand before, just jump to the next topic. Later, you guys can revise from the,
Monal S: class, okay? But if you don't understand this one, again, you're going to lose two different concepts. Abstraction. Very simple, again.
Monal S: abstraction.
Monal S: So, abstraction, think of it as, like, contract.
Monal S: Okay? Abstraction, think of it as, like, contract. Now, what you are doing… what you are doing…
Monal S: Let's suppose you are a company,
Monal S: what company I should name it.
Monal S: Very simple, yes. You are a company called as Tata, okay? Tata, you are specifically talking about cars.
Monal S: division, okay? Automotive.
Monal S: Okay, you're specifically talking about cars.
Monal S: So, when Tata build cars, they have some contracts, they have some SOP there, We should have 4 doors…
Monal S: In normal, traditional cars.
Monal S: I know, folders is what we will see most of the time. And then we should have 4 wheels.
Monal S: We should have, engine We should have an engine, we should have windshield.
Monal S: And when we are doing welding, we should have around 300 points welding.
Monal S: Okay? Weld, welding the matter, okay? We should have all of this. Now, let's suppose Tata is creating a new car. Tata is creating a car number 100. A new car, a hundredth… this is the 100th model, okay?
Monal S: Before creating the model, before creating the car and its design, they will first see what we as a Tata
Monal S: have. This is the contract. So, they will try to follow. My design should have 4 doors, 4 wheels, 1 engine, 1 windshield, and 300-point welding. If I do 280-point welding in my design, I should not be called as a Tata Automotive.
Monal S: So what I'm trying to do here, I'm trying to kind of create a contract that you should first follow before creating a new car.
Monal S: A contract I should follow before creating a new car. What this will enable us? This will help us… this will enable us to create more
Monal S: Standard classes. More standard cast. Standard, which Tata has written.
Monal S: So, who writes this standard?
Monal S: Tata writes the standard.
Monal S: Who has to follow? Tata has to follow.
Monal S: So, is everyone clear with this contract, guys?
Monal S: Is everyone clear with this contract?
Monal S: Awesome.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Done. Now see this.
Monal S: To create a contract in Python, to create a contract in Python, we call it as abstract class.
Monal S: Okay? We call it as abstract class, or we call it as a interface.
Monal S: Okay? Interface-like, Python does not use a word called interface-like, Python uses abstract class. So for people in Java, this is interface, but we call it as abstract in Python. Abstract class. Okay? And this is nothing but contract.
Monal S: Now, this class which we're talking about does not hold any logic.
Monal S: It just tells you what you… what are the must… what are the must things that you have in your class. So the first thing, everyone, see this? The first thing is, we need to write this code, we need to write this code from ABC
Monal S: import… ABC comma, abstract method.
Monal S: First, I'm talking about how to create a contract. Serious.
Monal S: How to create a contract. So let's suppose I am a new bank.
Monal S: I am a new online bank.
Monal S: I am a new…
Monal S: online bank, and I want to have minimum things which industry follows. So, industry follows what? You should have a way to
Monal S: pay to some merchant, or some people, or you should be able to get a refund from some other merchant. Yes? Either you pay or get a refund. Right now, you want to have this contract, and every bank in the world should follow this contract. So, let's create this contract.
Monal S: Let's create this contract where we should have pay and refund.
Monal S: So, the first thing which I told is, we should write… the first line is ABC. So, what we are doing, we are importing ABC.
Monal S: ABC is abstract class. AB is abstract class. And then, we write abstract method.
Monal S: So we need to import two things from ABC, from ABC. Don't worry, I will talk about what is this from. But for now, just write, from ABC, we are importing
Monal S: ABC, and abstract metal.
Monal S: Is the first line clear, guys? Only talk about this first line. Is the first line clear?
Monal S: We are importing A, B, C, and abstract methods are two things we are importing.
Monal S: Just like we imported OS, we imported other things, we are just importing ABC and abstract method.
Monal S: Guys, just like we imported, OS…
Monal S: I'm importing ABC and abstract method. ABC full form is abstract class.
Monal S: Abstract class. ABC Abstract class.
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: Forget this.
Monal S: forget this formula. This is… a package.
Monal S: Okay? Package we have not learned yet.
Monal S: Done.
Monal S: Definition and why we use it.
Monal S: disable the chat.
Monal S: What is this I'm doing?
Monal S: What is the definition?
Monal S: See this.
Monal S: Second thing is, we need to write the class that is the contract name. Let's write this contract as payment.
Monal S: This is a contract called as payment. This contract should inherit ABC to call it as an abstract class. This is requirement number 1.
Monal S: Requirement number 1.
Monal S: Okay? Any class should inherit ABC to call it as an abstract class. This part is done. Okay?
Monal S: Why this is creating this? Okay, yeah, done. Next!
Monal S: What things we need?
Monal S: what things we need to follow as a bank? We want pay and refund. So let's create… let's create DEF pay.
Monal S: DF pay, and in this pay, we want all of them to follow this argument.
Monal S: Self, amount, currency.
Monal S: Okay? I want all the people to implement this. Pay, currency, and pass.
Monal S: That's all. It does not have any logic.
Monal S: Second is refund.
Monal S: Second is refund self, comma amount. How much amount we want to refund? That's all.
Monal S: So, this is the main contract I mentioned. Contract name is payment. It has two pay and refunds. So, any bank who want to do the refund needs to follow this contract. They need to write the code for pay and refund. See this?
Monal S: One second requirement is… We need to write, at the rate.
Monal S: abstract method on top of the function. This is called a decorator, which we will learn later.
Monal S: Decorator is next class, guys, okay? So, we need to write this decorator on top of this function. So, how many contracts? We have two methods. We need two methods in this contract called payment. So, let me write this.
Monal S: Contract called payment.
Monal S: As… two methods, in the contract.
Monal S: Which, all banks needs to implement.
Monal S: First is pay.
Monal S: Second is refund.
Monal S: So, this is the contract. Done.
Monal S: Now, let's suppose I'm creating a new bank code. I am the new bank, I am creating IPAS.
Monal S: Okay? For IPLD. This is my new bank, IPLD Bank.
Monal S: Okay? So, to first apply this contract, I need to inherit payment.
Monal S: I need to inherit payment.
Monal S: That is the requirement. This contract is created only once.
Monal S: And you as a company, you want to always follow that contract. You will apply… you will tell your developer that there is a contract called as payment, that use it.
Monal S: And don't use contract in interview, this is just for your understanding. Call it as an abstract class. So, abstract class, if I inherit anything from the abstract class, it means I always have to write the logic.
Monal S: Here is no logic. If I don't write any logic.
Monal S: it will throw an error. So, see this? If I write its own logic, DF, new user.
Monal S: Self.
Monal S: And I will do print.
Monal S: Hello.
Monal S: Done. Let me create the object of this class, which is inheriting the contract, and the contract is inheriting abstract. This payment is abstract class now, so let me try to run it.
Monal S: OBJ?
Monal S: B1.
Monal S: It is saying that you cannot even initiate a class without the implementation of these two methods, pay and refund. It is telling that you inherited the contract, but you have not written anything. You are not defining the contract. Invalid. So let's do that.
Monal S: If we don't implement, see this, contract is saying we should have amount and currency always. So let's copy this whole thing.
Monal S: If you don't have the same amount of variable arguments, it will also throw an error. If you don't use it, it's totally fine, let's not use it. But in the argument, it should be present. It will match exact as it is.
Monal S: I will write, pay.
Monal S: Next is…
Monal S: Refund. So see, if I only implemented pay, and let's run it, now it will say IDBL Bank without an implementation for refund. Only refund is left. So now I need to also…
Monal S: Implement the refund in my code.
Monal S: It should be present. Whatever the logic is, it does not mind, but…
Monal S: it should be present. Now, if I run it.
Monal S: object is created. So, once the contract is satisfied, it means both of them. If I remove the amount.
Monal S: even if I remove the amount, you can see this amount, where I'm using this amount, okay? Now, let me call this refund.
Monal S: we are able to get the refund, okay? So let me see if we are getting the same thing. Just wanted to check that does it follow? It should follow, actually.
Monal S: But here, it is kind of following only the name.
Monal S: Otherwise, it should say error.
Monal S: Just wait a guys, okay? Just wait a second.
Monal S: Oh, it is letting us create,
Monal S: arguments, okay? Argument matching is not its job here. It should do that, but for some reason, they have not implemented this, but yes.
Monal S: Object matching, argument matching is not required, okay?
Monal S: Let me double check.
Monal S: Yeah, they don't enforce it.
Monal S: Okay? They don't enforce it.
Monal S: None… This is, kind of… Arguments matching, not… mandatory.
Monal S: So here, we just need to implement the pay and the refund. So if it is not matching, let's not even mention it, but for an example, I'm just writing it here, so that you will know that we have one without an argument, one with an additional argument. It still works.
Monal S: So, refund we are able to run, and we are also able to run pay.
Monal S: So if we don't implement it.
Monal S: we will not be able to create our bank. So this is just to define that standard.
Monal S: Alright?
Monal S: So, this is it. I think if I do more coding than that, people will not be able to understand today's class further. Yes?
Monal S: So guys, are we able to understand this abstraction?
Monal S: There are multiple set of rules that you need to follow, and then done.
Monal S: Just a contract. Just a contract that you need to follow.
Monal S: You guys need to revise it, guys, okay?
Monal S: Post days?
Monal S: import ABC and abstract method, just write this code, you will understand after a few classes what is this from ABC. But you need to import ABC and abstract method.
Monal S: You need to recreate the contract. So, this is the contract called payment need to inherit ABC. Then, whatever method you will write, you need to write this adverit abstract method always on top of the function.
Monal S: So, if you write 10 functions here, class inheriting this contract, or abstract class, needs to always implement it
Monal S: or I use it. If I use pass.
Monal S: Because I implemented it. I chose not to write anything. But if I don't even write anything here, then that will be an error.
Monal S: Okay, is everyone clear now?
Monal S: Are we clear?
Monal S: Okay, so can I do the recap of today's class?
Monal S: Guys, if I don't do inherit of ABC, it will not work.
Monal S: This is the first requirement, this is the requirement number two. You always need to follow the requirement.
Monal S: Requirement number 2. Requirement number 2.
Monal S: No need to write logic. This class does not require logic contract. Think of it as, like, you are creating Google Form.
Monal S: You are creating Google form of first name, and you are saying asterisk here. How many of you know what is asterisk?
Monal S: Asterisk means what, guys?
Monal S: And there is a submit button. Until and unless you fill everything, asterisk will stop you to submit the button. It is required. So think of this as, like, you are creating a Google form with asterisk.
Monal S: If you don't do that, you will not be able to fill it. Is this part clear now?
Monal S: So, using… this is a Google form named payment, these are the fields, and you're making it mandatory. So, whoever is using that payment to create the bank now, they should follow it.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Okay? Understand. So guys, did you like today's class? Is it complex? Object-oriented programming is complex if you don't practice it.
Monal S: If you don't practice it.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Guys, it is complex because there are a lot of code. Did we… did I wrote any mathematics?
Monal S: Is there any mathematics here?
Monal S: Variable is where we store. Object is a type…
Monal S: Tanma, I told you this, yes or no, Dhma?
Monal S: Tanme, what is this?
Monal S: Here, I wanted user to not write something, and I want to initialize something. Then I'm using init.
Monal S: Superintend I want, if I have seen.
Monal S: Everyone?
Monal S: Understand this. This is for everyone.
Monal S: If I have a big file of my Android operating system, this is my Android operating system. Everyone understand this. I'm disabling the chat.
Monal S: Understand this.
Monal S: This is my Android device. Here, I've returned the functionality of my start button.
Monal S: off button.
Monal S: Functionality of app drawer, functionality of notification, functionality of menu, functionality of search, functionality of app theme, functionality of app grade, and everything.
Monal S: Now, this created…
Monal S: This created… 1 million lines of code.
Monal S: 1 million.
Monal S: lines of code.
Monal S: You as a developer, you as a developer, is now working on Android OS.
Monal S: you as a developer is now working on Android OS, okay? You're working on Android OS, and your task is…
Monal S: Task is to fix the… icon… and… adjust the… Box, width, and height.
Monal S: This is your task.
Monal S: Now, in this 1 million line of code, you need to find that 2-3 lines of code which is using that.
Monal S: In 1 million line of code, do you think it is kind of little unmanageable?
Monal S: It is not little, but do you think that this is kind of little unmanageable?
Monal S: Others, chat is enabled.
Monal S: Do you think that is unmanageable?
Monal S: Two, three lines of code out of this 1 million rows of lines of code.
Monal S: So, what we have developed, this is called as procedural programming.
Monal S: How many of you know procedural programming? I taught you procedural programming, yes or no?
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: Procedure programming works, but on a bigger scale, things become complex.
Monal S: So what we will do, we will follow a different method of coding. Object-oriented programming. It means we are doing programming from
Monal S: Objects. Classes and objects.
Monal S: Okay? Then, what we will do, I will create a separate class for icons.
Monal S: I will create a separate class for notification.
Monal S: I will create a separate class for something. Similarly, I will have… I might have 1.5 million lines of code using this method. Nikita?
Monal S: Not now, okay? People are not able… people will not be able to understand, but I want to.
Monal S: I have to take doubt as well.
Monal S: Right? Which will be otherwise 2, 3 PM.
Monal S: This is 1.5 million lines of code, but now all of them has its own code separated. Now, if I have to look for…
Monal S: adjusting the icon, I will look into the class, which is handling the code only for icon, Yes?
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: But is this class icon only depends on icon?
Monal S: No. Class icon will also be dependent on theme.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Theme is also dependent on Your system-wide theme?
Monal S: If you have chosen dark theme, maybe it will be a little darker, then the icons will be a little different.
Monal S: So, this connection from one class to another class you can get from Super.
Monal S: This class values variables will only be active… this class variables will only be active when we create an object. Let's suppose this one object is not created. Do we have an ability to create… to initialize its init?
Monal S: Do we know that? So, only when we require it, we will use it. When we don't require it, we will not use it.
Monal S: If this class is already initialized, do we need to initialize with super.init?
Monal S: If these variables are only initialized, do we need to do that? Others…
Monal S: If the variables of theme class is already initialized, do we need to initialize from icons again?
Monal S: Note.
Monal S: Are we able to understand what we are trying to do?
Monal S: Based on the requirement, we will choose to write any or not.
Monal S: We will choose to write some function or not.
Monal S: But we need to think in terms of scale, that in this class, if I don't provide init, then other class tomorrow who wants to use icon and its variable inside the init, if the init is not present here, will this class be even able to invoke with super
Monal S: Will this class be even able to invoke the super?
Monal S: No.
Monal S: So, if you always follow a standard, are you safe from tomorrow's error practice?
Monal S: Are you safe from tomorrow's extra work?
Monal S: So, in Python, in Python, encapsulation
Monal S: Encapsulation does not provide you security.
Monal S: The main task of encapsulation is design.
Monal S: You are telling other vari… you are telling other developers that there is a variable called as hello. Feel free to use it.
Monal S: But there is a variable called as hello. Please try to… this is a way to communicate. Please try to use, within the classes methods and inheritance, I'm fine.
Monal S: Please try to use it only within my class, otherwise you are the one responsible for security issue.
Monal S: So, I am communicating… are we able to communicate just by underscores?
Monal S: Are we able to tell other developers just by underscores?
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Now, this is about variables. We can also have the same for method, use it, Use it. Use it.
Monal S: If I always update the variables inside the private method, then I'm also safe from little bit of… I'm also gaining more security.
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: So, encapsulation is giving us a development tool, and also a communication way to tell other developers, this is what I mean, and this is what you should follow. That is encapsulation.
Monal S: Inheritance… what is the use of inheritance?
Monal S: code reusability, and to create a better structure. Even before writing code, think in terms of, today I'm creating this class, what can I do to make it more usable for upcoming tomorrow's problem statement?
Monal S: If I'm able to create class in such a way that tomorrow, if new class comes, they can also use it
Monal S: But if I only create for today's work, then tomorrow's class… then tomorrow problem statement might not be able to inherit it, because it is not useful. So what we are trying here, we are creating code reusability by using
Monal S: Our logic, what we should do, this is, again, design pattern. We are choosing. What is the next topic? Abstract.
Monal S: Abstract. I am a bank, I am a bank, and I have created a contract for customer onboarding.
Monal S: Customer onboarding. So whenever a new customer comes, suppose in this bank, the first customer comes is HEDFC.
Monal S: Second is SBI. They're a different kind of bank. Anytime a new bank comes, that developer has to follow the contract always in order to have the standard code.
Monal S: So, are we able to create these two new classes with the same standard? Every method is same?
Monal S: Yes?
Monal S: Everyone tell me?
Monal S: Yes, and this example of abstract, you will also understand why it is important in tomorrow's class of polymorphism.
Monal S: So, are we able to understand why exactly we are doing something
Monal S: Because that is a contract.
Monal S: contract, we are telling it that that should be present, Satish. I told you just now.
Monal S: We need to override. If I don't override, it will create an issue.
Monal S: So, encapsulation, are we able to understand data hiding, scope, contract, and code reuse? This one is short, it will not take long, polymorphism tomorrow, but it is already 12.36.
Monal S: I will take some doubt, but again, guys, if the doubt will come from things which I already told you, you need to revise. I think from my side, I have covered each and everything.
Monal S: Why do we need a contract?
Monal S: Exams.
Monal S: Nikita, listen.
Monal S: In my exam.
Monal S: Do you want student A to get 30 MCQ, student B to get 5, student C to 100, Nikita?
Monal S: Nikita?
Monal S: Do you want this? Multiple students getting different number of MCQs?
Monal S: It's very fast.
Monal S: What you will tell… you will tell the instructor that your contract is 100 questions, we require 3 set of 100 questions.
Monal S: If I give this instruction, do you think that this case is possible now?
Monal S: Do you think that this case is possible in the exam?
Monal S: You have made all the three sets standard. Standard, this is your contract.
Monal S: Negita, we clear?
Monal S: Is everyone clear, eyes? Others?
Monal S: Chat are being picked at convenience, or there is method of finding guys.
Monal S: Really, this is how you guys chat.
Monal S: That is being picked at convenience.
Monal S: People who are… I'm reading chat, are you guys paying me extra money?
Monal S: Please don't say all these words in your interview.
Monal S: People… Will not.
Monal S: There are many queries I've posted.
Monal S: Guys, people are posting, but I wish you could… you can see all my chats.
Monal S: I really wish you can see my charts.
Monal S: Okay, Amish?
Monal S: You are next.
Monal S: So guys, thank you very much for joining today's session. I… and guys, please make sure that,
Monal S: you guys are revising, okay? Programming will soon be over, we will be jumping to data science tools next, but the programming part, if you're able to understand it and practice a lot, once you have become a good programmer, then all of those things will be very simple, okay?
Monal S: Amish, are you there?
Monal S: Guys, I will first take the query, I will upload the zip later, okay? Because if I do this, then again, the class will always extend to 1 or 1.30. After a class, I will do it fast.
Monal S: Coppish… It's not answering.
Monal S: Push it.
Monal S: Tushil is next, then Preetam.
Pritam Agarwal: Hello.
Monal S: Hello? Hey Pritam. Yes, nice class is over.
Pritam Agarwal: That's possible.
Pritam Agarwal: Yeah, yeah, thanks. So, just wanted to… can you share your screen and just…
Monal S: Hey guys, see you, bye-bye.
Pritam Agarwal: Yeah, just, I wanted to convert the, super method when you use for the initializing, in the motherboard example.
Pritam Agarwal: Can you hear me?
Monal S: I can hear you, yes?
Pritam Agarwal: So, just, yeah, this is the same query, yes, yes, this one. So, when you are initializing here, this variable is going back to the,
Pritam Agarwal: the motherboard inherited.
Monal S: This is going to the motherboard object in it.
Monal S: It will go here, it will initialize all these values, now motherboard will be initialized.
Pritam Agarwal: So, one, one logical question here, as init is also one of the function, or one of the methods, it is, like, if you don't use the super, is it, like, overriding also here?
Monal S: I mean to say, suppose I… start TJ from…
Pritam Agarwal: Start is a function. Start is a function. When we use the same function name in another class.
Monal S: It can override, but init will… init is only… init constructor is attached to a class. It can only be one per class.
Pritam Agarwal: It's attached to a class, even though init is the same repeated word.
Monal S: And it is a special method, it is not a normal method, it is a special method, yes.
Pritam Agarwal: So here, RAM will be initialized, we are initializing Super RAM, CPU, and it is going back to the motherboard RAM and initializing from there.
Monal S: Yes, it is a part of motherboard, so it will initialize here, yes.
Pritam Agarwal: So the value it is taking from the computer motherboard, right? Whatever the value first we are defining, it is.
Monal S: We are the one passing into the init of computer, then we are the one choosing it to pass to some other class.
Monal S: We are first catching in the computer, then we are the one deciding that whatever we call, we want to again share with the superintend. So it will go here.
Pritam Agarwal: Thank you, Monal. Thanks for your patience and amazing class. Thanks.
Monal S: Thank you.
Monal S: Alright, Sushil, you're next.
Monal S: Guys, we have 15 people, okay?
Monal S: Don May?
Monal S: I told you, right? You need to practice that.
Monal S: Guys, logic building you will learn. Assignments, I gave you a lot, a lot of assignments.
Monal S: I'm going next.
Monal S: Okay? Please watch it if you still don't understand. See, this kind of thing, try to think of a scenario. First scenario, if you are…
Monal S: If there is a need to initialize variable, then it will use init.
Monal S: Okay? So right now, because you have not seen a lot of, bigger examples, complex examples of limited programming, it is a little hard to understand at the start that why to use SuperNet.
Monal S: But, that part will be getting the clear data, okay?
Monal S: Guys, after class, I will share, okay? In the community, I will also share.
Monal S: Turn up?
Monal S: Ed?
Monal S: Vinay, you're next.
Monal S: Good night.
Vinay: Hello?
Monal S: Hi, Mona, can you hear me?
Vinay: Yeah, thank you for the section. I can able to understand the MRO, I mean, method resolution order concept, but I have a question with your example. If you don't mind, can you share your screen and go to that example? I think Class A, Class B, Class D.
Vinay: Yeah, this one.
Vinay: And here you are calling… yeah, this one. You're calling class D, right? So…
Vinay: After that, it will go to the super unit, which is the Class B.
Vinay: Yeah. In Class B, or…
Monal S: According to MRA.
Vinay: Yeah. In Class B, you're calling the superintendent, right?
Vinay: That's…
Monal S: Right? The superintendo of this one, from the code itself, you're able to see, hey.
Vinay: Yeah, yeah, it will go to the class A, right?
Monal S: But from the MRO, what is the next chain?
Monal S: B class is connected to chain of C, even though we have written A, but because of C, D is connected to BC. Can you connect D both to BC in a sequence? Can we follow a sequence when something is going outward in a two-direction?
Monal S: Can you go both left and right in a single time?
Vinay: Okay.
Monal S: Then the priority will be the C.
Monal S: Then, the MRO will check, because we're not able to go in left and right, and everything should be in a change, everything should be in a sequence, MRO will now decide a new sequence. D will go to B,
Monal S: B is going to A, but here, what will happen to the C?
Monal S: D is connected to C as well. We cannot create a chain. Chain means a single sequence, right? So, A go to B. What will… where will C go? Right? C is lost?
Monal S: Okay.
Vinay: Okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah, oh yeah.
Monal S: to create that sequence, so now that C is going to A.
Vinay: Okay, Malam, thank you. Thanks for the question.
Monal S: Yes, Pranav, can you please raise your hand? I see. You're trying to share hand, but if you don't speak.
Monal S: Sprano, tell me?
Monal S: Yeah, I'm Dale doing the same thing.
Monal S: Not able to hear you, Prada.
Monal S: This was happening before as well.
Monal S: Vitality, you are next.
Geetanjli Mathur: Hi, hi Monal. Thank you so much for an amazing session today. Just wanted to check with you, can we… can you please go to the example which you just explained?
Geetanjli Mathur: the MRO1.
Geetanjli Mathur: Yes.
Geetanjli Mathur: So, I actually wanted to check with you if there is any way we can change the… maybe we can code in such a way so that the sequence can change, in MRO, within MRO. Don't use this.
Geetanjli Mathur: Okay.
Monal S: So if you use this, then it will create an issue.
Geetanjli Mathur: Right, right, right. But given…
Monal S: manner, which I told you.
Monal S: Huh.
Geetanjli Mathur: But given the fact that we have D, and within the brackets we have B and C, so is there any way to logically, anticipate what the MRO sequence will be, instead of
Geetanjli Mathur: I said, comment.
Monal S: with a probability. Anticipation comes with a probability that something might can change, right? If you have a probability, then it means that it's not a sure route. If you want a sure route, what you will do?
Geetanjli Mathur: Then in print tomorrow.
Monal S: Then, use multi-level.
Geetanjli Mathur: Okay.
Monal S: Pretty clear. Here, smart wallet has everything, because it has TV. TV has device, so you are creating that channel. Here, you are defining your own sequence. SmartBault to TV, TV to device, yes.
Geetanjli Mathur: Yes.
Monal S: This is pretty straightforward, right?
Geetanjli Mathur: Yes, yes, yes, this is… I don't have… I don't have confusion in this, actually, only in that one. And so I think this is clear to me, but can we also go to the motherboard example? I had one question there, also.
Monal S: In metabolores? Yes.
Geetanjli Mathur: Yes, yes, yes, this, this only. So, the same thing which somebody, asked in previous question. So, instead of writing super dot underscore underscore init, as in, super dot init, can we, write super dot any of the other functions within the class motherboard.
Monal S: Yes.
Geetanjli Mathur: That will be possible.
Monal S: Okay, that will be possible. That will be possible. Where was I using it? Yes, see, if there is a new function which is not present here, like, if I do super.start, will be able to call it?
Monal S: Super is the previous class, we were able to call it, yes.
Geetanjli Mathur: Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Monal S: Okay, but usually what we do, the point of inheritance is, when we are inheriting it, why do we call it super when we already have it in ourself?
Geetanjli Mathur: Hmm.
Monal S: Are you getting my point?
Monal S: We cannot call, we cannot call any of the motherboard using self. But using self, because we are doing the inheritance, we already have all the methods of the motherboard
Monal S: those cells?
Geetanjli Mathur: Right.
Monal S: has access to everything. Are you getting my point?
Geetanjli Mathur: Understood. So, with Seth, we can, we can read motherboard also.
Monal S: Because it is inheritance, right? But inheritance does not allow us to call init self. When we do self.init, it means its own init.
Geetanjli Mathur: Understood, understood, understood. Thank you so much, Monal, for your patience. Thank you.
Monal S: Dave, I want to bust…
Monal S: See, I'm going… slow means I'm already catering to each and every. We need to understand that.
Monal S: After revision, is it getting solved or not? They were able to understand it. After revising, are you guys able to understand it or not? Because live class is supposed to teach you everything.
Monal S: that if I cater each and every one's speed, then… It'll be very slow.
Monal S: Let's see, let's see what I can do.
Monal S: Are you there?
Monal S: There is a class A, not sure why Class A has this bracket when we are not inheriting anything.
Monal S: So, let me remove it. This is Class V inheriting from this, Class C editing B.
Monal S: Class D narrating B and C both, okay?
Monal S: So, this is done.
Monal S: what we are doing cannot create a consistent method resolution. See, if we are not… it will… if it is not a problem… see this, let me create this. Let's see how your flow looks like. It is used for damage problem when we are not able to resolve it.
Monal S: So, this is D.
Monal S: From D, you want to inherit B and C.
Monal S: B and C. What B and C is doing? B is inheriting from A, C is inheriting from B.
Monal S: This is not resolvable, this is not a diamond problem. When we have this path, then it is okay. When the path gets complex, even Amwara will not be able to solve it. So, Pranay, it is good when you have these two things, okay? The diamond kind of a problem, when you have something like this.
Monal S: So, then it can solve it. Otherwise, MRO cannot solve everything. It is just a program, right?
Monal S: Are we clear? This is your current path, looks like.
Monal S: Is this dead?
Monal S: Rana, are you clear?
Monal S: This is not just a diamond problem, okay, everyone? So…
Monal S: Always try to also understand that. Draw things, and then you will get a little bit of more charity.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: Good talk, turn up.
Monal S: Next one up, I'm Andre, lowering your hand. Thank you for asking that. Yes? Sure.
Monal S: Monday's done. Prince, you're next.
Monal S: Hey, Prince!
Priince: Hi, Monal.
Monal S: Hello, audio.
Priince: Can you please, again open this class ABCD1?
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: This is Artist, huh?
Priince: So here, B… C and B both are going to Class A, right? But.
Monal S: So, we last week, not today.
Monal S: Be able to understand this.
Priince: There only I was in confusion.
Monal S: A to B to C.
Monal S: B also going to A, C also going to A. This is called a diamond property.
Priince: Okay, that I understood, but I'm not missing the result we are getting, the brain output.
Monal S: Did you do a try, run?
Priince: In Driverton only, I was getting confused. Class A is not printed only.
Monal S: So, why not? They printed Class A anywhere. See, this is MRO. We need to follow MRO. MRO?
Priince: means we are going to… we are going to Class A. No.
Monal S: Never went to Class A. Nice, C, C.
Monal S: from D, this is D, right? What did I print it? I printed the object of D.
Priince: Okay. So, from D…
Monal S: When we go to the sea, Does C calling any super?
Monal S: C is not calling any super. Are you able to see?
Monal S: Okay. So until the A, because it is connected, it is… it shows us the full sequence from this A. Because C is connected to A, you're able to see, we are inheriting.
Priince: Okay. But…
Monal S: It does not mean that we're calling the super of A. We are not printing it.
Priince: Okay, there, I don't… I hadn't seen that super.initiate. Otherwise, it could be in class A, right?
Monal S: Yes, yes, it will also go to Class A as well, okay? Because the MRO says that that is the next, the C super is A5, so we will go to the A after, okay?
Priince: Okay. And, one more thing.
Priince: in the last lecture, on Wednesday's lecture, you told that the word VEDA itself, the first one in init or in any of this, that's the connection, right? So, you gave an example of a robot, means if in robot 1, the connection is R1, then in robot 2, connection is R2. But here, for all these classes we are defining.
Priince: the connections are self, then won't it be getting confusing for the system? I was just careful.
Monal S: Self, self is inside a class. This self is inside its own class.
Monal S: So, connection inside is known as its own connection.
Priince: Okay.
Monal S: Class is a separate entity, just like this robot.
Monal S: Just like this rover, these arms, the wire that it is connected to, it's its own connection.
Monal S: It's not…
Priince: So…
Monal S: The robot, when it is connected to the same wire, will not say, can I communicate here? Okay? So, it is the same connection.
Monal S: Inside, no, inside. Self is used for inter… it is a lo- think of it as, like, local to the class B.
Priince: Okay, that's local for… okay, fine.
Monal S: Yeah.
Priince: So we have to not use any different words, right?
Priince: for connections.
Monal S: You can use different, but you can use self here.
Monal S: If you want to use… You offer, in place of self, you can use… Yes, yes, yes.
Priince: Oh, okay.
Monal S: In place of cells, you can use anything. I told you, right?
Priince: Yes, that I got.
Monal S: Cost variables should all be the same, yes.
Priince: Okay.
Monal S: You can use anything else, it's fine. Here, you can use self, here you can use AA, here you can use B.
Priince: Nope.
Monal S: But don't use that variable elsewhere, otherwise it will create an issue.
Monal S: That's why, if you're using A as the first argument, don't use another variable A inside this class.
Priince: Okay.
Priince: Okay, thanks, thanks. It was a nice lesson. Thanks.
Monal S: But, you need to check how Pyth works.
Nitin W: Yeah, I won't.
Monal S: Hey, Nathan.
Nitin W: Yeah, hi, how are you?
Nitin W: Okay, sir, quick question regarding that ABCD, classes, which you showed. So, can we just share your screen and go to that example?
Monal S: Does everyone have issue with ABCD?
Nitin W: Yeah.
Monal S: In the chat, anyone tell me how many of you have issues with the ABCD.
Monal S: Chad, people who raised hand?
Monal S: Everyone queries ABCD, then I will explain the whole thing again.
Monal S: What is the issue? Can you write it? What is the issue?
Monal S: Let me know, okay? Give me a second. If I know that everyone is having the issue with ABCD, I will explain it again, so everyone's query gets all in a single shot.
Monal S: Okay, can you tell me your query? Because I think everyone is asking the same query.
Nitin W: Yeah, yeah. So, over here, yeah, in class D, we are passing B first, and then C first, and then we print the MRO. It is saying that, class D, then Class D to B, then B to C, and C to K. So if we change the order, let's say class, in Class G.
Monal S: Yes, Class D.
Nitin W: Okay, if we change the model, let's say we put C first, and then D, B second, MR.
Monal S: I am!
Monal S: No, check it. Python will decide it, right? I cannot decide. Python will decide the change. That is MRO work.
Monal S: Have you tried it? Have you tried it?
Nitin W: No, I didn't tried it, but just stick with it.
Monal S: This is a permutation combination. Check what you did, check what is the output of MRA, then Python will work according to the MRO.
Monal S: everywhere, Python will decide it. That is called as a function, it will decide what is there.
Nitin W: Okay, so it is all random, or means, how it is?
Monal S: We need to… it is not random. The function is written, but we need to check function. Now, if you ask me how RAM works, RAM is not random, right? A bigger function is written that is going to decide it. We need to check what exactly MRO is.
Monal S: Okay? MR is, again, a different concept, it is…
Monal S: are not in our current scope in Python.
Monal S: Yeah.
Nitin W: Okay, okay, yeah, good, yeah.
Monal S: Yes.
Nitin W: Thank you.
Monal S: Alright, is everyone's doubts clear? Guys, all the things is regarding the same thing.
Monal S: the issue, but if you have this diamond problem, only if you have diamond problem, MRO will be able to solve it. If you have some kind of a conflict, then it will create an issue.
Monal S: Hirsch, Jen? Yes, Hirsch?
HarshJain: Yeah, hi Mul. Yeah, thanks for this amazing session, first of all. Yeah. Mul, actually, the last one, which is this content app section, so you were explaining. So, there I have some doubts, like, so why do we, like, if you can open that notes…
HarshJain: Yeah, this one, yeah. So, if we don't, define… I mean, declare this as above, class, payment class, then…
HarshJain: I just want to understand, like, why are we declaring this payment class?
HarshJain: As a prior one.
Monal S: Because I, as a developer, if I, as a developer, want whoever is creating an application, suppose I'm your manager, okay?
HarshJain: Okay.
Monal S: And I want my 3 employees to welcome 3 different things for 3 different clients. All of them are bank. One is IPLT, one is X, one is Y, okay? If 3 developers, I will give them work, they might use… they might use a method called as…
Monal S: pay to. They might use a method called as refund meet guests?
Monal S: But the functionality might be same.
Monal S: But all of them are using different function names, but doing the same task. Now I'm like, why do we even do that? Can I create a structure? Can I create a hard code?
Monal S: Yes. So, that's why I will create a contract and ask my developer to inherit it, and once they inherit it, all of them have to implement pay and refund. There is no other way around.
HarshJain: Okay, so we kind of a structure… We have Google.
Monal S: Yes, yes, yes, see, if this Jupyter notebook, which are able to see in VS Core, Yes.
Monal S: Yes, Sam?
HarshJain: Oh, sorry to interrupt, go ahead first.
Monal S: No, no, no, no, can be 10, yes. So we don't need to define any logic in this payment class, right? It's not mandatory. No, it is…
Monal S: It is… it is not about logic, it is about enforcing the name and what you need to implement.
HarshJain: Okay.
Monal S: This is for enforcing it, creating the standard, okay? I told you, just have Google Form. Google Form does not ask you value what value you will pass, but it should have first name, last name, mobile number. Are you clear?
HarshJain: Yes, yes.
Monal S: with Google Form. This is a Google form, and developers, once they get it, they like to fill the values.
HarshJain: Yeah, and also we have to define this abstract method, means this is an entry.
HarshJain: For that, any of the methods.
Monal S: Otherwise, it will not create an abstract.
HarshJain: Thank you.
Monal S: abstract method on top of method. In class, inherit abstract class. This is abstract class, abstract method.
Monal S: On top of method, use this method. Any class, use ABC.
Monal S: Okay.
HarshJain: Okay, so ABC is an inbuilt class, right? Inbuilt, means feature for…
Monal S: It's another class, yes, at Sheffield.
Monal S: Yes, you can see class.
HarshJain: Yes, yes, got it. Yeah, thanks, thanks for…
Monal S: Okay, one thing I want to ask all of you guys, how many of you feel the class, is getting faster?
Monal S: No, whatever is…
Monal S: On your mind, please tell me. Class is fast? It's fine. Tell me it is fast, it is not fast.
Monal S: temperature.
Monal S: This is smooth now. Okay, okay. For people who are staying fast, just wanted to ask, is it getting resolved after watching the class recording?
Monal S: Everyone?
Monal S: Is it getting resolved after getting… after watching the class recording and practice?
Monal S: 3 class in a week is making us fast. Yes, I understand, guys. Okay.
Monal S: So… Yes, this is the problem I want to understand.
Monal S: That, guys, if you don't revise the class, I will tell you, I will tell you one very important fact that you guys have to understand. Where is my notion?
Monal S: I'm sharing my screen.
Monal S: Everyone who is my student, okay?
Monal S: It is not my duty to tell each and everything, but it is my duty
Monal S: As your mentor, to show you the reality.
Monal S: I hope everyone is able to see this.
Monal S: My screen? Everyone?
Monal S: This is our curriculum.
Monal S: This is page number 5.
Monal S: Page number 5.
Monal S: And currently, we have a few things left, which I will talk about later. Map function with us, which I will do at the end, okay? Not at all really required. You can always go with that.
Monal S: Page number 6.
Monal S: And we have object-oriented programming. Currently, we are here. We… tomorrow, we will learn polymorphism and other things, material things.
Monal S: File handling, we have done, so we are not going to the SQL, we are going to the C++, which we feel is good. Exception handling, we have also done. So, advanced Python programming will also be done soon.
Monal S: Then, what we will do next is…
Monal S: This is NumPy, page 7, page 8, page 9.
Monal S: Machine learning is on page number 50. We are in page number, we are in page number. Others.
Monal S: VRN page number?
Monal S: 5 and 6, somewhere in between.
Monal S: Let's go to the end.
Monal S: Page number.
Monal S: Do you think RV is keeping any content?
Monal S: Anyone here, do you think are we skipping any content or depth?
Monal S: Are we skipping any little bit of depth? I think I'm teaching more than what is required in the Python also.
Monal S: People who know Python, they might agree on that, that this is more than what Python they already know.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: So, the point is, I'm not target… this is not about target, this is about telling you guys that, guys, you have to do a lot of hard work.
Monal S: you don't even imagine that once you understand Python, there are a lot of things that we need to cover. V means you as well, okay? And if your target… if your target is to complete 36 pages of syllabus in this course and done with it, then, guys.
Monal S: There is a bad news waiting at the end of this course.
Monal S: You are in an era where AI is able to do the code. Everyone is here. How many guys agree? Everyone is here to get a job tomorrow, day after tomorrow, one year after two years. They want to be good with AI. How many of you are here for that?
Monal S: Yes. Others. Tag, non-tag.
Monal S: Indian, foreign, people, yes.
Monal S: So, our goal should be worried on, I'm not able to grasp the speed, or our goal should be why I'm not able to grasp the speed.
Monal S: If depth is being taught in the class, and
Monal S: It's not like I'm skipping anyone's question. There are some people who say that I'm not looking at the chat. I'm looking at the chat, whatever I'm able to do, okay? I'm not an AI, cannot take everything.
Monal S: But if I, as a mentor, is doing everything I can, more than everything I can, what is your next part? Everyone's, everyone here.
Monal S: Is this your end goal, guys?
Monal S: Is this your end goal? Page number 32, let me zoom in.
Monal S: Is this our end goal?
Monal S: So, what is lacking from our side? Everyone, people who are… even who are doing practice. What is lacking from our side?
Monal S: In relation… Practice.
Monal S: Understanding, and having an ability to learn things fast, guys.
Monal S: If you say that, sir, I know maths, if you say, sir, I know maths.
Monal S: I'm able to do calculation, I was good in my 8th class, does it matter now? It does not matter. What matters is, whatever is in your current skill set, you have to learn that fast, not like what you were doing before.
Monal S: You should have an ability to learn things far, that it's a skill that everyone here, everyone as my student needs to learn.
Monal S: Else, after this class, you still have a lot more things. What you will do?
Monal S: What will you do?
Monal S: Amon, I just…
Monal S: replied that I'm not… looks like not able to see them. Guys, am I able to see everyone's hand, but one by one.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: So, if you feel like class is fast, but information present is correct, then it means V…
Monal S: As learners, leads to learn.
Monal S: needs to find our own way, our own shortcut, but after class, maybe I will use ChatGPT, because I know 70% or 60% of the class, maybe I will revise quickly, not by watching the recording, maybe I will know it. If not, maybe… what will happen if I watch the recording at 2x, 3X, or only that part?
Monal S: Is everyone clear?
Monal S: So guys, trust me, this is the skill which you not learn. I'm giving you more skills, but I cannot give you skills to learn things faster.
Monal S: The please, please, please, remission is not a target. A target should be…
Monal S: Finding out how you can practice things, and
Monal S: with, the same dedication. Everyone.
Monal S: Okay?
Monal S: Great, awesome. Charlene, you're next. Thank you for listening, guys, thank you. Charlene?
Shailendra: Yeah, hi, Marl.
Monal S: Hello, yes.
Shailendra: Yeah, just small doubt, and be ABCD example only. Just, as I well know a little bit Java, I'm a little bit getting confused.
Shailendra: You already covered a lot of things, and then go to the code part. Actually, B… Code part. B is,
Shailendra: super of… A, right?
Shailendra: Yeah. So, Class B, you written B is super…
Monal S: Right? Super.init. So, ideally, it is narrating game, yes.
Shailendra: And super.init, ideally, it should go to A, right? Basically.
Monal S: Right? It should go to A coding-wise, but in the runtime, see, this is not runtime, this is compile time. You're from Java, I can say runtime, compile time, right?
Shailendra: Brilliant.
Monal S: This is compile time, but in the runtime, it needs to first solve this DBC.
Monal S: Okay. Which is a diamond problem.
Shailendra: So, because of B, C, it is going into C. Ideally.
Monal S: Yes, because…
Monal S: There is no chain between B and C. See, between B and C, there is no chain in all the three classes.
Shailendra: so B is inheriting A, and ideally, if you're calling super, ideally, it would go to A, right? Because A is a…
Monal S: object of B, it will always go to A.
Monal S: there is no ambiguity here, but because of the ambiguity, MR is… MRO needs to solve it, and that is creating this weird thing.
Shailendra: Behind the scene, MRO is deciding.
Monal S: Yes.
Shailendra: So, when we will write the logic, so how we will know, in real time, when…
Monal S: Usually, we as a programmer, we should not go to the part where we see a word called as ambiguity, which is not in our control.
Monal S: In Java also, this is there because it creates an ambiguity. When we learn Java, this is the first thing that we learn, right? That we should not, inherit multiple things at once. Because, which one is first? We never know. To not have that part, we should use what?
Monal S: We should use one layer, multiple… multilateral.
Shailendra: one way.
Monal S: Okay, okay, got it, I got it. Okay.
Monal S: So, always… If there is an ambiguity, let's not try to use it, but does Python support it? Yes.
Shailendra: So, whenever we will implement in real time, we should also accept it can go to any place.
Monal S: Yes, now again, Python is telling developers that you are the person, you should worry about that, okay?
Shailendra: Thank you. Thank you, Mara.
Monal S: Sure. Bye.
Monal S: Tahul… Yeah, I'm with confusing words. Yeah, no.
Shahul Hameed: Thanks for the class, Mona. In fact, you answered my question when you were answering Vinay, about MORO. I also come from Java background. Just one, not on the ABC class, all I want to understand is… Yeah, but in that… so the question is around that, but this super keyword, right? I think in Java, we are super in this keyword. Okay, I'm not going to come
Shahul Hameed: keyword. With respect to the super keyword, generally in Java, we say that it should be the first line of your statement in a method. Does this rule apply here as well for Python?
Monal S: Usually, when we write coding, it's not about the rule here, it's about the intent, right? And usually, the intent of the super and other things… see, here I'm able to use it later as well. I showed you, right? I was able to use it inside the function, I was able to use it outside the function, outside the method, yes.
Shahul Hameed: Huh.
Monal S: So here, there is no rule like that, but the intent, what we get from the Java is like, yes, we should choose super, because whatever we want to do from the upper class, let's do it first, then let's try to do the thing next, okay? So it's more about development, okay? Okay, okay.
Shahul Hameed: Okay. I mean, I could have Googled about it. Yeah, but I know I would miss some nuances, because you've been working on Python, right? So I thought I'll ask this question right.
Monal S: That is more about development here. See, Python, as a language itself, was made, so we don't have a lot of constraint. You can see, in Java, we have things like the type needs to be mentioned for the variable. That makes it a strict programming, but also strict programming makes us a better developer, right?
Monal S: But Python removes all of those nuances. You're able to see that the encapsulation also. Python is giving us workaround and is putting the load on the developer that now it is your responsibility.
Monal S: I will give you methods, but I will not give you strict types of anything. Yes, yes, so Python is made more like that. Java is more strict language, but yes, that is strict makes us better developers, I mentioned.
Shahul Hameed: Now, all these years, I've been told multi-level is not possible. I know Python is possible, but then I could see practically how it is happening, and how they are resolving the ambiguity problem using MRO. Anyways, thanks. Class was very wonderful. Thanks, Melissa.
Monal S: Sure. Cheers out. Thank you.
Monal S: Right?
Monal S: Amol, finally you're here. I can see too, Amul. Amol?
Monal S: And there are two of you.
Amol: Hey, hi.
Monal S: Family.
Amol: Hi, Monal, thanks, thanks for your session. So, even, myself, I have a C-sharp background, like, similar to Java.
Monal S: Same thing in C-sharp?
Amol: So, no, the multi-level is there, multiple is not there, okay, similar to Java. What took me off was, you know, the private variable that was accessible. So, you mentioned that there is a workaround through which we can access private variables.
Monal S: I showed, see, I showed Workfront for people who thinks that, okay, this is how it is working, but we should know the nuances of the language, right? In Java, it is not possible.
Amol: Exactly. But what… what is shocking to me, you know, right, now that we know that workaround, right, some developer can't directly access that private variable and update the balance.
Monal S: I will tell you, see. If I talk about the code part, once you run everything in this object in a package, right.
Monal S: If someone can access your computer outside you, it means your system is already hacked.
Monal S: what system is vulnerable with, system is vulnerable with your… someone who can access, scripts in your system, right? If someone can access scripts in your system, then that means they can access your data. But if someone cannot run scripts in your system, it means they cannot access your data, okay?
Monal S: And they cannot access your database? They cannot have access to variables.
Monal S: So if someone is already in your system and is able to run files, it means even if it is C++ or Java, they can access your variables.
Monal S: Okay.
Amol: If we go with that example of balance, right? Wherein you were actually able to update the balance from outside.
Amol: So, that's…
Monal S: to update the balance from outside. Yes, that is true. And.
Amol: And maybe you, you did clarify that using some decorators, like, we can have a protected.
Monal S: There will be a separate property setter and getter.
Monal S: We have to enforce this, that will enforce this. But for now, see, as I mentioned, encapsulation at this stage in orbit… oops, so Python itself says that this encapsulation is not for security.
Monal S: It is for better design, okay? It is for better communication between developers and also to help them choose better design patterns that… what we should allow, what we should not allow. Later, once we know that, we will apply the security. This is not about security here, encapsulation, at least in this stage, not about security.
Amol: Okay. I'll just wait to hear that how exactly we block from updating that balance.
Monal S: I haven't sure of that, yes, true.
Amol: Okay, thank you for all these sessions. I mean, me, myself, being a developer, having a C-sharp background, I do understand all these concepts, and… but I'm glad that you are with this space, so that the beginners are able to understand it in a granular level. So, thanks for that.
Monal S: Thank you.
Amol: Yeah.
Monal S: Hey guys, developers who know coding really understands that, this depth, I should… as a data scientist, as an AI engineer, you should not… you're totally fine not learning all of this in depth.
Monal S: You will not use it in your development day-to-day. But if you understand it, it will help you become a better developer overall, okay?
Monal S: That is my goal.
Monal S: Avni, you're next.
Monal S: Me?
Monal S: Hey, Monal, thank you so much for this session, appreciate that.
Avni Yadav: Can we go to that motherboard? I have a very quick question.
Monal S: Sure, sure, sure.
Avni Yadav: There was something called, self.os equals to self. Yeah. So if you remove the self on the right-hand side and just put the check, you mentioned it would be an.
Monal S: work. No, it will work.
Avni Yadav: Good news.
Monal S: Huh? This is a variable of init.
Avni Yadav: Got you. The right one I'm talking about.
Monal S: A white one, then it will not work.
Monal S: See, Python itself is giving you that it is not defined. It means inside unit, it is trying to check, but in class, everything is connected with self.
Avni Yadav: If…
Monal S: It will try to find in the connection. Is it present in the connection? This name? Is it present in the connection? No, it is present in the self-connection.
Avni Yadav: Gotcha. So, every variable that we have to define in a class, it has to come… it has to be prefixed with a self.
Monal S: Yes, again, depends on you. Either you want to use
Monal S: Something like this. And if you create, if you create some kind of a function inside this.
Monal S: Okay, now it is not giving me entered error, right? But this does not make sense.
Monal S: Right?
Avni Yadav: I don't know.
Monal S: Yeah, so you can do it, but we are… this connection itself is mandatory. I know that Python should have found a way that without writing this self, it should write that everything is connected to the class itself, right? But this is a way that we do in Python, and yeah.
Monal S: Yes, sir, thank you so much for that, I really appreciate that.
Avni Yadav: And thank you so much for this wonderful session. For me, it was a little bit faster, but I think I should be able to manage it. So yeah, thank you so much for that.
Monal S: Sure, sure, thank you, Mr.
Avni Yadav: Okay, take care, bye-bye.
Monal S: Bye-bye.
Monal S: All right, Good, actually?
Geetanjli Mathur: So, when we were talking about inheritance, could you please help me also understand that, for example, if we are, writing super dot, you know, and then the function name, maybe.
Monal S: Like, for example, Invis.
Geetanjli Mathur: So what… and you also said that we can also write self.
Geetanjli Mathur: To access, because it is inheritance.
Monal S: So, self is itself? No, no, self, we can use it for its own class. Self cannot be used for other class.
Monal S: Self is used for within class. Super is used for
Monal S: Class, parent class, that will inherited.
Geetanjli Mathur: Right, but in this, in this particular example, it is inheriting it from A. B is inheriting from A, right?
Monal S: Yes.
Geetanjli Mathur: So instead of writing super.init, or maybe, if we want to, just…
Geetanjli Mathur: having access to the function speak in Class A.
Geetanjli Mathur: Can we…
Monal S: already accessible because we did, we did A. So, when we do cell.speak, it is also same.
Monal S: Okay.
Monal S: This is saying, because we have inherited it, but we cannot call the init with self.
Monal S: Because?
Geetanjli Mathur: Self is a constructor tied to its class. We cannot inherit the constructor.
Monal S: directly, okay? Both of them are same, but we cannot inherit self.init, because init is also here, init is also here, so it is typed.
Geetanjli Mathur: So, super is… super is generally for init only, or we can access another function also?
Monal S: is for this whole class K, we can access… we can access this variable, we can access init.
Geetanjli Mathur: Understood. Understood.
Monal S: But cell is specifically for if we inherit, use this, else, and the other methods and variables.
Geetanjli Mathur: Okay, understood. Okay. Thank you so much, Mona.
Monal S: Thank you.
Monal S: Okay, yeah, there's… Praveen? Hi, Praveen.
Praveen Girotra: Hi, Monal. I'm really sorry I missed today's entire session.
Monal S: What? Do you miss today's entire session?
Praveen Girotra: Yeah, yeah, I just joined now, I was, you know, driving. Monol, I have one request. You know, while I understand it takes 24 hours for the recording to be uploaded, is it possible, you know, just today we prioritized, because I would really love to watch the entire recording
Praveen Girotra: Before we start tomorrow's session.
Monal S: I understand. See, what happens is that
Monal S: 24 is the maximum. Our team does it less than 24, because once Zoom is ready, and the person who uploads that is ready, they directly upload it. So, it's not like we take 5 more hours once the recording is ready. We might take 1 more hour, 2 more hours.
Monal S: reporting is ready.
Monal S: No, I would appreciate…
Praveen Girotra: Because this is going to be a fundamental problem, you know, for people who are missing on Saturday, because if I join tomorrow, I'm going to go, you know, blank in everything you speak, so…
Praveen Girotra: If you can put in a word, you know, so it helps in general.
Monal S: Yes, yes. See, we try the best. Shahul has mentioned that. I have seen it within 6 hours. Okay. Once it is ready, but we cannot call Zoom and ask them to process it fast, because.
Praveen Girotra: No, I understand that challenge. Maybe you can put in a word, only for Saturdays, every Saturday, you know, if they can prioritize, because Sunday, Wednesday, it's okay.
Monal S: I understand, yeah, yeah, yeah, we have time, right? Yes.
Praveen Girotra: Thank you, thank you, Monarch.
Monal S: Yeah, thank you.
Monal S: All right, Amol? Amol? What you've done over the time?
Amol: Hello?
Monal S: Hey, thank you very much, guys. Thank you.
Amol: Hello, hi sir, I had a question, I had some questions. So, first question is, sir, I see that we are able to access the methods that are defined in the class.
Amol: after the constructor init function within the init. What I mean to say is, like, how is the sequence of code interpreted in the class? That is, is it from top to bottom, or is it, like, everything is absorbed.
Monal S: In classes and procedure, we do it top to bottom. In classes, it depends on what we are calling, because this is a separate object. Object is like when we want to call it.
Monal S: Int is also object, 1 is also object, 1 plus 2 is also object. If I write 1, I can write, 1.0. So, it depends on what I am writing. It is not on sequence. Sequence, we define here in object-oriented program. If I do class.
Monal S: All of this is a blueprint. Blueprint, when I create an object, pay, refund, new user, all of them together will be available in the RAM.
Monal S: If I call refund first, it will give us a refund. If I call new user first, it will give me a refund. But in terms of init, init starts from top to bottom. Whatever is present in the init, it starts from top to bottom.
Monal S: So, init, top to bottom. Now, there is another init, so it will jump from here, go to this part, top to bottom. Then go back here, whatever's the next line, it will come back here.
Amol: So, so what I mean to say is, so in this example, like, like, initially you had, uncommented this self.os, right?
Amol: So, the last client in the unit, yeah. Self.o is supposed to…
Monal S: This is the same name.
Amol: Yeah, yeah, okay. So what I mean to say is that, now the definition of this function is below the unit, right?
Amol: So, if we go… First?
Monal S: In the compiling time, Python is both interpreter and a compiler. First, it will check. During the compile time, it will create what?
Monal S: it will create, it has a computer, it has init, it has super, it will not call anything. Compiling time is just understanding and writing all the things in stacks and queues. So, computer, init, checkOS, it will decide how many functions it has. Is this part clear?
Amol: Yes, sir.
Monal S: Once it has everything, then while running, it will check you're trying to call init. Motherboard.
Monal S: This is in it. It already know it has… motherboard has start, stop, because it has already compiled. It will come back here. Now it is checking, do I know this function? Yes. While compiling, I know this function. Let's call it. Call it.
Amol: Okay, so, so you mean that classes are, like, compiled… is a compiled.
Monal S: Everything is compiled, everything is compiled into the byte code, then CPython runs. CPython passes the instruction to the operating system, then an operating system runs it.
Monal S: Banarify.
Amol: So, but, so, but, like, Python is an integrated language, right? C is, C, C++ are…
Monal S: Python is not… see, if you check anywhere, no one will say Python is interpreting. Python has interpreter, but every code needs to be compiled, and then, goes into the bytecode.
Monal S: Okay.
Amol: Okay.
Amol: Even if you do…
Monal S: the interpretation. Interpretation also needs to be converted to what?
Monal S: Finally, code?
Amol: Yes, sir.
Monal S: Right? Yes, yes, it's 10.
Amol: Miss, what I meant to say is, like, if we had a normal… a normal sequence of code lines, that is A equals to 1, B equals 2, C equals 3, then… and so… and then… then in that case, like, C will not be available at the time when A has been assigned equals to 1, right?
Monal S: Yes, one by one, yes, yes.
Amol: So, but in this case, we are able to fetch the function which was defined.
Monal S: See, variable is different. Variable values get executed line by line, but variable things will be done. But in terms of definition, if you check function definition in any programming language.
Monal S: function definitions and other things works differently. They get stored into the stack and other places, and then Python starts executing them. So, function and classes is different from how variables and other things execute. Even if I do A equals to add, this will… this will run, this is…
Monal S: The code will be compiled, but the value will be initialized when you run the function in the runtime.
Monal S: Right. So, that happens later, but the compilation, during compilation, value does not get stored.
Amol: So, I think, sir, in case of class, the blueprint is stored in, like, as you mentioned, like, the blueprint is stored, and then when the object is initialized, the complete blueprint is available to the object.
Monal S: Yes, it is all… no, Blueprint is already available in the RAM. Then, once we start executing, it takes that Blueprint, it already knows that this particular class has access to this, so it already has the mapping.
Amol: Yeah, so the object has the complete…
Monal S: Yes, yes.
Amol: Like, available to it.
Amol: Otherwise, we are able to access.
Monal S: Yes, exactly.
Amol: Like, later on. And then the second… and then the second question was, in the, ABCD, that example, in the MIO thing.
Monal S: Yes, yes.
Amol: So my question was, if, like, if D was only inheriting, B, and not C, then…
Amol: then it could have called A, right?
Amol: Yes. Then we print…
Monal S: Then, David.
Amol: would it be?
Monal S: B will be A, A will be this, so this is what?
Amol: So, in that case, it would be printed.
Monal S: In that case, it will not be even, multiple, it will be multi-level.
Amol: Yeah, it will be… it will be multi-level, and it will print A, right?
Monal S: Yes, yes, yes, it will go to life.
Amol: Okay, and the second question was, like, suppose, B was… B, or Class B was not inheriting A, then would the sequence would still be same?
Monal S: Why? If it is not inherited, then it will stop at B, but we should not be calling super.
Monal S: Super is for targeting to the A.
Amol: No, no, I mean, D is… I mean, D is… D is inerating B and C, but, means everything is the same, except B is not inerating A.
Monal S: The issue is, D itself has two paths to decide, D and C. So MRO needs to solve this part first, because we don't know the sequence of B and C.
Monal S: then B will go to A, then this part needs to be solved.
Monal S: The first issue is this. If this is not there, MRO will not be one invoked. It does not have any issue here.
Amol: Okay, miss, bees…
Monal S: When you have multiple paths, then there is a decision. When there is a decision, MRO needs to run and decide it.
Monal S: Am I allowed to solve all the ambiguity.
Amol: Okay, Ms. It's because we are…
Monal S: Yeah.
Amol: So, so means we are trying… so MRO is basically, we are trying to decide which is the… which is the, actual, actual super parallel.
Monal S: Yes, actual super… not actual, just decide the super…
Amol: the actual…
Monal S: There's no word like actual. If I give you two lines, tell me the secrets.
Monal S: If I give you two lines, tell me the sequence. Is there any sequence which connects both of them?
Monal S: No.
Amol: So, you know…
Amol: So, in this case, will… Yes, yes. So, so in this case, will she be the… be the only parent, or… or how is it?
Monal S: to run what? You need to provide me the code and run, and check, check with IMRO.
Monal S: If it shows you that it is fine. Otherwise, do pen and paper and understand that what is… anytime there is ambiguity, that is not in our control, what is going to be there, but at the end, we know what is going to be the C. A is parent. We already know that A will be the parent.
Monal S: But in between, we did not know that it will go to the B to see how B and C is going to be connected. That part we never knew, but we knew that A is going to be the last element.
Monal S: Yes? Because C is also A, B is also A. It means A is the last one.
Monal S: Here's the last one.
Amol: So, when, when B was executing, B, B was executing, then, when, like, B is calling the super of B, right? So, super of B is A, so why is, why is it not able to print…
Monal S: From the B and C, do we have that connection? Did it solve? Is this level solved?
Amol: Okay, first it will solve this, and then only it will…
Monal S: See, from C to B, it has some connection, right? So either, either you will see, either this path it will go.
Monal S: It has only two ways. Either go this, or go this, because B also has a connection to A, C also has a connection to A, yes?
Monal S: C2A is also in one of the inheritance. B2A is also… so there is only two path, yes?
Amol: Late.
Amol: No.
Monal S: Scope?
Monal S: There is only two ways. Both of them here is giving us the answer, a sequence. Are you clear?
Amol: So, and, and last question, like, sorry for this. So, suppose if we, while, while defining D, suppose, if we had mentioned C before B, like, so in, in that case, would A would have printed?
Monal S: Create, right? A is the final one. But if B is not inheriting, then that will be a different sequence.
Amol: No, I mean, everything is same, except when we define D, we, like, instead of BC, we mentioned CB.
Monal S: See, that part… what is the word here?
Monal S: Ambiguity.
Amol: Ambiguity.
Monal S: If I don't do the code and run it, will I be able to know the answer?
Amol: For sure. Okay, okay, fine. Like, like, we need to experiment, and then,
Monal S: You need to check what Python decided, because the part is ambiguity, okay?
Amol: Right, right.
Monal S: Are you clear?
Amol: the real algorithm, how it decides that is still.
Monal S: Yes, that is runtime. You can read more about it, how each implements, but that is implemented here.
Amol: Okay, okay.
Monal S: Yeah. Thanks for thinking. Yeah, sure, you're welcome.
Monal S: Alright, I'm almost done.
Monal S: Here, to one more.
Monal S: Yadav? Ayad.
Yadav: Yeah, hi, Murdo,
Yadav: Just a query, not from Discuss. Actually, I joined the session on 4th of Feb, okay? So, I was going through all the recordings,
Yadav: So, I was going through a couple of assignments which you have given, okay? So, my query is that…
Yadav: Let me share my screen.
Yadav: Should I share my screen?
Monal S: Please join as a panelist.
Yadav: My screen visible?
Yadav: Hello?
Monal S: Sprint is not visible.
Yadav: Not visible.
Monal S: It is visible.
Yadav: Yeah. I was going through the assignment part, okay? I have no issue regarding the assignment. Only issue is that in the Visual Studio, when I'm trying to execute this code, it is getting executed, but when calling the function, this is taking time. I'm not sure what exactly this is happening.
Yadav: Same when I do in the Jupyter, it gives me the output.
Monal S: No, it is running because it is asking you for input. Provide any input.
Yadav: Yes, so, that pop-up is not confirmed.
Monal S: No, it is coming, I can see. It is on the very top of your screen.
Monal S: No, no, no, don't scroll. Just over your mouse. I can see, enter the access code it is writing.
Yadav: This one, right?
Monal S: It is writing on top of your screen.
Yadav: I'm not able… oh.
Monal S: Yes, yes.
Yadav: this one.
Monal S: See this? On top of it, on top of it, a little bit, there is a…
Yadav: Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, got it, got it.
Monal S: Click on the gray box, click on the gray box.
Monal S: Yeah, it is working.
Yadav: Yes, my bad. My bad, really. Sorry for this.
Monal S: No, no, sure, it's fine. This is new time, right? Yeah, okay.
Yadav: Yeah, I am used to the Jupyter part, but not I'm used to to the visual part.
Monal S: Visual Studio, this is a little weird that it gives on top, but yeah, we can.
Yadav: Yeah, because I was searching in the bottom where it's getting.
Monal S: I hate it.
Yadav: Then I clicked on…
Monal S: It happens, it happens, it happens, I know. In terminal, it is pretty standard that you can get in the terminal, but here it is weird.
Yadav: Yeah, thank you, thank you, Model.
Monal S: Yes, yes, hello.
Monal S: All right, okay… Muhammad? Hey, Muhammad.
Monal S: Thank you very much, Keith.
Monal S: Muhammad, are you there?
Monal S: Okay. Arun, next.
Monal S: Guys, Arun will answer questions now.
Monal S: I don't…
Arun Kumar Tangirala: Hello. Can you hear me? Hi, Monal. Hey, thanks for, thanks for the session, Monal, it's really nice. My only question is, I mean, I know it's a bit too premature to ask this question, do we have something like Java, like, Java reflections within Python, Monol?
Arun Kumar Tangirala: something, like, to know, to reflect and understand what is there in the class, the real-time programming. Do we have something like that in Python?
Monal S: they might have… there are a lot of frameworks. So, need to check, because I personally don't use it. Java, Reflection, and Python, let me just check, because maybe I'm familiar with the traceback.
Monal S: attributes of Opsy. And, you're talking about when you print object, you can see what are the things available in object? Right, right. It is available.
Monal S: It is available, yeah. You will be able to see what each and everything that code is. Later, I will tell you, because the object has a lot of different properties, but I'm not sure that what Java gives us exactly.
Monal S: But we have things. You will be able to access all the variables, hidden variables, and hidden methods of a class, which is… which you are not able to see directly, because everything at the end is a part of object class, right?
Arun Kumar Tangirala: Right, right.
Monal S: So here you'll be able to see all the attributes. But I've never known that you call it reflection, because in Java, I've not seen that.
Arun Kumar Tangirala: book.
Arun Kumar Tangirala: Gotcha.
Monal S: I will show you, I will show you. Yeah, sure.
Arun Kumar Tangirala: Sure, thank you, thank you.
Monal S: Thanks, thanks.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Monol, share a moment.
Monal S: Yes.
Monal S: able to share, but now you need to promote the… I'm promoting a panelist.
Monal S: Harold, are you there?
Arun Kumar Tangirala: You're asking me?
Arun Kumar Tangirala: Hello?
Monal S: Arun, yes, I… what is your query?
Arun Kumar Tangirala: No, no, I already asked you, you responded.
Monal S: Oh. Oh, okay, sorry, Muhammad? Sorry, one sec. Muhammad?
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Yes, .
Monal S: the query?
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: I, I just wanted to ask, one thing, that I understand, the super, what super means. Super means that, to go one level up, the function. And, the, the init, function, it means to read, what is in the class,
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: in the.
Monal S: And it is a constructor which runs… it's a special function that runs automatically when you create an object.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Okay, and…
Monal S: special function that runs automatically whenever you create an object from the class.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Okay, and, in it, reads all the, functions, in the class.
Monal S: Now, self is a connection that has access to all the things. AND is just a special function that runs once you… that runs automatically when you create an object for the very first time.
Monal S: It will only run for the first time in it.
Monal S: When you create an object, it will run for the one time. You cannot call it again and again.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Okay, like, you, you, typed the code, super dot, in it.
Monal S: Yes, yes.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: So… so it will run one time.
Monal S: Yes, it will run runtime.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: And it will get all the, things,
Monal S: Not all the things, it will… it will get whatever the things that is inside the unit.
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Okay, okay, understood.
Monal S: It's a function, right? So if it will run, it will get everything what is inside that function, okay?
B14A-129086-Muhammad Sharjeel: Oh, okay. Thanks, Mona. Thank you.
Monal S: Thank you, thank you.
Monal S: Alright guys, so we are done with everyone, answered everyone's query. No new raised hands, okay? Please don't raise hand. It's already 1.40.
Monal S: And thank you very much, guys, for joining today's session. Don't worry, I will create a zip and then paste everywhere, okay? As we do always. Thank you guys for joining, I will see you tomorrow. Please come revise and also help each other in the community, okay? Thank you guys, bye-bye. Good night.
Monal S: And good afternoon, good morning, whatever your region says. Bye-bye.